- Who's your best girl?
Who's your wife, Connor?
- Yeah.
That's it.
- No, because this is you can't do that,
that's a loaded question.
- If he can't answer within five seconds
then you don't have a wife yet.
- No, that's like saying
what's your favorite genocide?
There's no, someone's gonna be angry like.
(all laugh)
(soft upbeat music)
Hi, I'm the boy of the cDawgvariety
and today I'm with Jesus the carpenter man
he just built two chairs and Garnt.
Just Garnt.
- Yeah.
(all laugh)
- Just Garnt?
- Just Garnt.
Well, do you want something else?
- The Garnt the guy who
did not build two chairs.
I'm just tired for no reason.
- We've been building up
an office you can't see it
but yeah, there'll be some live streams.
- We?
Did you build two chairs?
- Yeah, I did what every
good white man, watch the brown man.
- Wow.
(all laugh)
- I was just sitting in
the corner on Twitter
and I was like, you guys got this.
- Yeah you guys got this.
- I remember where they
were building the pyramids
and there was one guy in
the corner on Twitter.
(all laugh)
- I was like the epitome of I'm helping.
- Yeah, you're helping.
- Moral support.
- It was labeling things.
We should cut off that shit
that we just spoke about,
this is a very inefficient
interrupt, all right?
Garnt, what are we talking about today?
- I don't know, what are
we talking about today?
(chuckles)
Well, basically the only
like new current topic
I can think of
- At the time
we're recording, of course.
- at the time
we're recording this is this week
Hololive English just
got announced basically.
(laughs)
What?
- Okay, no just.
- What are you laughing?
Why is that is it funny?
- I don't know, is just that if anyone's
gonna start topic, it's Garnt.
(laughs)
- Of course.
I've been following Hololive for a while.
And this week,
or maybe was it last week or this week
that Hololive English got announced?
And everyone's had their debut.
And then Twitter just exploded.
Oh, my God.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like I was in the
Hololive community before.
So I knew the usual suspects,
whose suspects would be
talking about VTubers.
- Right.
- But within the last week,
like my entire feed has just been VTubers.
And it's not just Hololive VTubers,
- Right.
- Fucking everyone's
coming out as a VTuber right now.
- Everyone is turning into a VTuber.
- Yeah, I don't know what it is.
And I'm right there with
you because I am a...
It's like coming out about benediction.
Because it's like, I'm
sorry but I have recently
fallen into the Vtube hole myself.
- Yeah.
- The Hololive hole and I can't get out.
- When you made that tweet,
it was like the proud father
who had just found out his son
had like won the baseball
game or something.
That's how I felt reading the tweet man.
- I don't know dad,
I didn't feel like I was winning.
- I'm glad to accept we had
a nice variation of opinions
on the topic is 'cause Garnt,
has been like the old boomer simp.
(laughs)
- The boomer simp of Hololive.
- He's been simping
since the first crumb of Hololive existed
we just got into it.
And I feel like an alien who's just come
to earth for the first time
and has just found out
about a religion he's like,
wait, so you will just
believe in this book?
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
Just take it 100% you'll just follow it.
- Yes.
- Give your money
to this book.
- It is a religion at this point.
- Yeah, I'm the altar
boy and he's the pope.
- So I felt like I didn't get it before
and now I feel like I must be like doing
like something is wrong with me.
- No, because--
- I'm like the only person
who's just standing being like,
so everyone's into this,
everyone likes this.
- No, I was there with you, right?
And then I don't even
know how it even started.
- Yeah.
- I think it's because I was just curious,
because this guy won't shut the fuck UP.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- So I'm like, all right.
All right, I'll give it a go.
Like I've worked with
VTubers in the past, right?
- Yeah.
- Kizuna Ai.
I worked with her and stuff.
So I'm like, all right.
Let me see what the stream of variety is.
- Yeah.
And I looked at Wan..
An hour passed.
- That's all it takes.
- And then two hours passed.
And then three hours passed
and I said oh no.
I've fallen and I can't get up.
(laughs)
- I've watched like a lot of the clips
because they come at my
recommended it's like,
someone someone says the N word.
(laughs)
- I think that's how it got viral
in the first place.
- Yeah.
- How I fell into the hole was like,
there would be some clip
that someone had read.
- It was always the GTA one
there's like a compilation
- Yeah.
- The (indistinct)
- Just like just like why
is like these anime girls
dropping the N bomb.
(laughs)
Like what is that about?
- I don't remember that
episode of Madoka Magica.
(laughs)
- And then after that,
it would be like that they
would jump like the F bomb
and then they would just be
like anime girls swearing.
And then eventually,
I was like curious
and then saw one clip,
it was one clip that
got recommended to me.
And it was well one of
the Hololive VTubers,
Fubuki singing Scatman.
(laughs)
And it's just this Hololive
girl like singing Scatman.
- That sound pretty good.
That sounds pretty fun.
- It's adorable as fuck, right?
And she does like a lot of covers.
And then it was one video, one video.
And then after I watched that one video,
YouTube recommended was like---
- Allow us to introduce ourself.
- Yo, you like this shit?
Yo, we got all this shit right here.
- YouTube recommendations very turned
into like the back alley of
like crack deal, all right.
I was just like, you want more?
I got some more for you.
- The worst is when Youtube like
autoplays video you did not wanna watch.
And then it will not stop
recommending that channel.
I never intended for this to happen.
Stop, stop this right now.
- Yeah, cause the difference between
just watching that one channel
and having YouTube recommend
this entire just one channel.
Like with VTubers, it's
watching one VTuber,
and then it's just a load of other clips
on other different channels.
- Yeah.
- That just get recommended
to you all at once.
I don't know what it
is about the algorithm.
But I feel like if you
just watch one, your lost.
- They kind of did it in a genius way
because almost all of
the Hololive members,
they almost always collab
with one another as well.
- Yeah, I've seen that, yeah.
- So it's just perfectly built to just get
once you start with one.
Then you see that one post in you're into
collab with another one.
You're like, oh, okay,
let me check this one out.
And then like tree branches,
just keep growing out
until you're way too deep.
- To explain what virtual YouTube is...
(indistinct)
- Let's first explain
what virtual Youtubers is
to an audience, to some people
who probably don't know
what virtual YouTubers are.
- In case you're watching this from 2012.
- Exactly.
So to basically explain,
to put it in the simplest terms,
it's basically real people
who rigged themselves up
with an anime avatar.
And they just make content
whether it be streaming
or YouTube content.
Now Now it's more about live streaming.
I would say like the first
real big VTuber, is Kizuna Ai.
As you probably know or not do not know.
But now I feel like the content is grown
so far away from what
the content was before
with Kizuna Ai leading the charge.
Because I felt like before it was all
about making just just
like YouTube comments,
not YouTube content.
- Content, yeah.
- And now it's more
like it's less scripted.
It's less scripted.
And it's more about live streaming stuff.
And I actually prefer that.
I don't know about you,
because I never really got into
VTubers before hololive
came along and really kind
of just took over the entire scene, right?
- I mean, there was a part
of me that when before
and after I did work with Kizuna Ai,
there was a time where I really did get
into the YouTuber side of things as well
because I found Kizuna Ai
and then I found like
some of the other big
ones like Shiro and Kabhi
Audrina and stuff like that.
Yeah, they're all of them
are like really entertaining.
There's a lot of really
entertaining VTubers out there.
But the problem is that the
content is just so confined,
like an average Kizuna Ai
videos like three minutes long.
It's really really short even
though it's a daily upload,
but now you have Hololive and Nijisanji
and these other like big
YouTube stream of VTube,
like organizations that stream
for like two three hours daily.
- Okay.
- So it's just constant
constant feed of content.
- As somebody who doesn't
really know anything about it.
- Yeah.
- Why is it not just Virtual Youtuber.
Why does it have the name Hololive?
What's up with that?
- Okay, so Hololive is just an agency.
(indistinct)
- Yeah, so they're basically
an agency that have all
these VTubers under this one roof
and it's more like a
branding thing, right?
- You want your like talent
to be under your name.
- It's like we will
have individual channels
and they have Trash Tastes.
It's not an agency but that's kind
of like the best way I can describe it.
- It's like back in
the day when YouTubers,
there were different
types of gaming YouTubers,
but then a lot of the gaming Youtubers
will under the machinima like that.
- Yeah.
- Because there are other ones as well.
There's Hololive I think the two big
ones a Hololive and Nijisanji.
- Yeah, right now.
- Yeah, right now,
but there's also all these other tiny,
tiny individual agencies
as well that have a bunch
of different VTubers under their umbrella.
- Yeah.
- And yeah, it's just
become like a branding now.
- I mean, I guess to
play devil's advocate.
(chuckles)
I gotta fucking bust up(indistinct)
What did he ask?
What stops it from just
being more than a gimmick
to you guys?
- I mean, it was a gimmick.
- I mean, like I said, Okay,
the way I see is just a new
genre of content, right?
Because there's there's
just something about VTubers
that they're not, you
don't see them as like,
real life streamers even
though there's a someone that
someone behind the avatar, right?
So there is someone operating it
but it's not you don't
view them as that person,
but you don't also view them
as a complete anime character as well.
So it like fits in this little gray area.
The best way I can..
(indistinct)
- It's a little bit creepy.
- The best way I can describe it,
it's it's kind of like wrestling right?
Where wrestling fans.
They know that the
people are like, acting.
They know Wrestling's fake,
but they still buy into it anyway, right?
And it's basically wrestling(indistinct)
- It's like a whole life
is interesting because
from the little that I've seen so far,
that the characters are
really human like when you
when you listen to them, yes,
they're obviously playing and
acting up this character and
this entire law behind the character.
But then every now and then the human part
of them slips out.
- Right.
- And that is kind of
charming to watch because.
- I can imagine yeah,
I've seen clips of, like,
stuff like that happening.
I remember what it was, yeah, they like,
break character for a second.
- Yeah.
So it's basically like
the best of both worlds.
- So like, I don't I don't
feel like it's a gimmick,
because the more I've gotten into it,
the more I'm just like,
man I can't really get this kind
of entertainment anywhere else.
And that's why I've become so addicted
to VTubers is because I
could never really get
into live streams.
I know, you've you've been really,
really into live streamers.
I appreciate the work they do.
I've just never been a guy who could sit
and watch live streams for hours.
I've always thought like--
- Yeah, I don't really
watch them for hours.
It's mainly like--
- It depends on the streamer right?
- Yeah.
Depends on the stream what's happening.
It's very much like,
I'll see what they're up to,
maybe watch 10 minutes
and go do something else.
Yeah, I don't really watch
streams and sit there.
I haven't really done that years.
- Yeah.
- But I don't know.
I used to...
I don't know why I can't
really get into it.
Like I watched the clips.
I find them funny,
but I feel no desire at all to like,
follow them around.
- Do you think it's the
language barrier for you?
- No, no,
I don't think so.
I think that's really,
I mean, especially
there's English ones now.
I checked out most of them.
Because I was like, well,
I wanna see if there's one I like
because everyone's just like, well,
it's easy to find one you like.
- Yeah.
- But when you don't like like one.
It's like, no, no.
But I feel like that some
people would say about like,
you should find a woman you like,
(laughs)
It's kind of like that.
- Yeah, because there are
like so many VTubers now
that I'm pretty sure there's
a VTuber for everyone.
Because that's how--
- There's something for everyone.
- A little something for everyone
- That's how you get into it, right?
Because a lot of the times,
like with Joey Yeah,
people didn't know why people go into it.
- I never understood it
until I found the couple
of VTubers where I'm like, okay,
I can vibe with this person.
- Yeah, yeah.
- cause for me when Kizuna Ai blew up,
I'm like, I respect the
character and everything,
but it just wasn't my kind of content.
And I thought it was just
a really cool concept.
But now, even if you don't,
even if you have some certain VTubers that
aren't your favorite,
there's gonna be one that you like, man,
I didn't think I was a simp.
But I think I'm about to simp man.
(laughs)
- I just like this.
I enjoy watching some like,
here's the iron mouse on Twitch.
I watched her about she's pretty funny.
- Yeah.
- But like, I wouldn't like say I'm like,
yeah, I'm gonna simp,
you know what I mean?
- Simp is a strong word.
But I mean, like,
you can have fun.
- I can watch the streams and enjoy them.
Yeah, but I see people on Twitter and
they're like fucking like,
it's like life or death.
- Oh, yeah.
- Like, you got an email
from someone, right?
That one time.
That was like, you wanna talk about that?
- Yeah, I guess I got an email
from someone who was like,
basically trying to get me
to teach the VTuber
advocates to like people,
like English speaking fans
who watch VTubers, right?
And I was just like, man,
I ain't getting involved in this.
- What do you mean?
Like they're not following
etiquette or something?
- Yeah, I can just chat shit while Garnt
pulls up the email for a moment.
- Yeah.
I mean, I guess I get them.
Maybe they don't understand.
Like, the whole simping thing.
- Yeah, I guess like with Hololive,
it's not that I don't necessarily
like enjoy or anything.
I do enjoy what I like,
I guess it's one of those things
where when you don't
feel nearly as strongly
as other people do.
It's kind of alienating.
Oh, because I wanna enjoy it.
But then I feel like
am I enjoying it right?
Because everyone else seems to be
so fucking aggressive about this.
- But that's the thing, right?
Is that when I first started watching it,
and this was only like
three or four days ago,
like fully started to get into it,
I just watched it like
just to check it out right?
Just like any streamer would,
and you obviously miss all
of these inside jokes that
are within the community,
but then the more you watch them
and the more clips you
watch them you like, okay,
so that means that like, okay,
I'm trying to I'm slowly
starting to understand,
like, the general flow of how
this particular VTuber
interact with their audience,
and I'm like, okay, I
either can get into that
or I can't get into that.
- Yeah, that's that's why they
call it a rabbit hole, right?
Because there's so much content out there,
that this whole that you fall into it,
there's no reaching the bottom.
And the reason there's
no reaching the bottom is
because there is no way that
one person can catch up
with all the content out there right now.
Even if it's just like,
even if you just follow
Hololive Japan even
that there's so many VTubers
that there's no way you can keep up
with everything that's going on.
- I mean, it's hard to catch up
with just one VTuber right because yeah,
most of these VTubers are streaming
three, four hours a day.
- Sounds like a normal streamer though,
like they stream jokes
they streaming a lot.
- But like what I found is
that with the couple of VTubers
that I have found we've really enjoyed,
they could literally be doing anything
and they just really entertaining
and that's really hard
to find in any streamer like VTuber alone.
- I can name a few streamers
off the top my head that are
pure entertainment.
- Yeah, of course.
I know a few as well but there's
something, there's a different quality
that VTuber brings I feel
that a live action
streamer can't really...
- Live action!
(laughs)
- 3D streamer
- Disgusting 3D.
- It's like the Netflix
live action adaptation.
(laughs)
- Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, exactly.
I like the anime version.
I don't dig the Netflix adaptation.
(chuckles)
- I don't know, I don't wanna say too much
because I think people will just be like
Connor just doesn't get it so but like,
I don't know,
to me at the moment at least
maybe next week I'll come
on the podcast and be like, gentlemen,
I've changed my mind.
- Yeah, I mean, like,
what do you think about basically
has your feed been like--
- Oh, yeah its been a little--
- It's been decimated by VTubers.
- Yeah.
- Cause I mean,
I think is we're right on the cusp of it,
like kind of becoming mainstream
in English audiences, right?
- Because everyone's
trying to be a VTuber.
- I think the next few
months will be crucial
in determining whether
it's gonna be a thing
that sticks around.
- Yeah, yeah,
- It'll be a phase of...
- Yeah, because I remember like,
I was very very surprised
when Pokemon came out
with a Vtube avatar.
- Yeah.
- And I know like Lily Picchu is about
to debut her avatar,
which probably will be
debuted by the time.
- Like debuting avatar.
Guys, I'm gonna release it.
- You gotta tune in to the debut.
That's what it's all about.
- See that's the thing--
- Okay, that is cool.
I'll admit, that's kind of cool.
- It's how to build up hype.
And it's part of like the law,
which is why I feel like,
which is why I feel like Hollolive English
really did this super well,
because they debuted
everyone at once it became
this massive event.
And everyone's talking about it now.
And everyone paid attention.
And now like, all of Western Twitter
and like Western streaming
communities will take--
- Like anime fandom is
really like our attacker.
- I feel like it's even
going out to that now.
- Yeah, I think it's out of that.
- Yeah, I've seen like,
plenty of tweets from a lot
of big streamers who are like,
what's this VTuber thing about?
Shall I get an avatar?
Yeah, I'm thinking
about getting an avatar.
- It's mainstream internet then?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I think so.
I think just like the
general, the younger audience.
- So when you're watching these YouTubers,
the VTubers, sorry.
Do you don't wanna like because to me,
I find what's super
interesting about streamers
is the person and yeah,
everything about them.
And like, what they choose to show.
- Yeah.
- And perhaps maybe they have a really
interesting like life before streaming.
Like, to me, I find the human aspects
so entertaining and that's I think
that's the reason why
I connect so much more
with documentaries and fiction.
Yeah, I think real life is
just so fucking interesting.
Because, you can't make this shit up.
Like the stuff that
happens in real life is
so much more insane than what happens
in someone's like, fiction--
- I think--
- And I wonder why you don't like
when you see a VTuber.
Like when I watch VTuber,
all I'm thinking is like,
I wonder what the real person's like,
I wanna see I wanna like talk to them.
I wanna--
- I think though, that
whole thing just isn't--
- It's completely covered by just the law
as a character.
- Yeah.
- And like how they present
themselves as a character
is just so entertaining
that you almost forget.
Oh, shit, there's a person behind this.
- I guess it's why I
could never really get
into wrestling either.
I never really cared about that.
- I never got into wrestling either.
(indistinct)
- I'm sure there's someone can explain it
some fucking PhD in the comment.
- Yeah.
- As they always fucking explain it to me,
but I have no idea why
I just can't connect
with the avatars.
I think again, like it's funny the way
that like a clown dancing in front
of me will make me laugh.
Yeah, like that's cool.
- Here's the way I view it.
Because the reason I go and see VTuber was
this modern day iteration
is VTube is because
someone like Kizuna Ai,
I saw completely as a character.
- Like, I have no interest in Kizuna Ai.
- Yeah, like, I saw her completely
as a character.
And what kind of drew
me to Hololive VTubers,
was that it felt like they
did have a personality behind them.
That was you--
- There definitely is.
I've seen it, right.
- Yeah.
Because you have times
when they talk about
it's past stories about what they did
as a kid and some aspects.
- I've seen one of the Japanese
ones always telling stories.
- Yeah.
- The green-haired one.
I don't know what the fuck is.
(laughs)
- I'll try and find it(indistinct)
- But that's the thing, right?
Is that the difference
between the VTuber YouTubers
Versus the VTuber streamers
is that almost all of
the VTubers YouTubers,
were entirely scripted.
So it was very difficult.
They were really controlled,
like they were controlled
as to how much of themselves
(indistinct)
- But it's weird, right?
Because the streamers
a not scripted, right?
Because it's a live stream.
So they actually have
a lot more flexibility
in what they can show of how
much of a person they are
or how much of a character they.
Like, I remember I saw recently,
there was a clip of one
of the characters who...
The Laurel of her character
is that she's like in her teens,
but then the character, who
has a voice in the character
slipped out a little bit being like,
yeah, as a late 20 year old
and people in the chat when like late 20s.
You're in your teens?
(laughs)
Yeah, yeah.
I'm in my teens.
Yeah, yeah, sorry.
I didn't mean that.
- Dumb teenagers.
- But then as the community
was egging her on about,
like late 20s she just
completely just gave up
and was like, yeah,
I'm in my late 20s, fuck it
and she just rolled with it.
And that side was like very
human and very entertaining.
- Which is why I feel like I was saying
they exist in a place
between being a character
and being a human.
It's just really weird.
- I think that streamers
do that there as well.
Like, I mean, like,
(indistinct)
- But they ain't cute
anime girls, are they?
- Tyler1 is pretty cute.
(laughs)
Like, everyone knows
I fucking love Tyler1.
I think Tyler1 is such a fucking, amazing
natural entertainer
and like for example, the age thing,
he's got the whole I'm six foot five
and he has a whole fake ruler.
Yeah pulls out in the stream.
He's just like, obviously like five foot.
- Yeah.
- But that's like that's like
the same kind of thing right?
It's almost WWE in that aspect
but he's obviously not that fucking insane
in real life.
No one can be.
(indistinct)
- But like the only
difference between that
is a fucking add a cute anime
girl in between that, right?
(indistinct)
- To me it's like almost
scarily impressive how someone
who's on camera constantly
can keep up this act, like--
- It is impressive.
It is super impressive.
- I think live stream
is a fucking psychopath.
(laughs)
- I don't know what it'd have to be.
- Because you have that
beautiful thing of like
when you have the Hololive,
it's doing the work for you.
You just gotta put the
voice, which is easy.
- I say that as a YouTube creator
with total fucking respect.
- Yeah.
- I have no idea how you
guys fucking do that.
- I don't know how 'cause
two hours of streaming
and I start to like lose my energy.
- Yeah.
- How Tyler1 can be
screaming for 12 hours?
I don't know.
- I don't get it.
- Like after I'm like
streaming for two hours,
two hours is like my limits,
anything off past two hours
I'm like pushing...
I'm like running on empty.
- Yeah.
- Whenever I stream I press
like the end stream button
and I go my couch and I collapse,
after two fucking hours.
- It is really fucking tiring
and we have we all have friends
that can do fucking eight
nine hour streams daily.
I'm just like, how do you do that shit?
- I fucking left my
stream on the other day
when I thought I turned it off.
- Really?
- I left my house
and then some people
were tweeting me like,
yo, your stream still on bro.
And I'm like what?
I checked and it was just on.
(laughs)
I looked at like the final
10 minutes before I left.
- Yeah.
- And like I go like bye guys.
(laughs)
You guys can go and see this.
I don't know what the--
- At least you didn't
like jerk off on stream.
(laughs)
(indistinct)
- Like could you imagine,
if I was just like done (indistinct)
(laughs)
Like that's just my thing when I'm done.
- Just stand up and the
dick just flopping out.
- God, I just hate that group of people.
(laughs)
Okay, Tyler1 become a VTuber dude,
just I'm saying that that
would be fucking insane.
We need a VTuber that
screams like Tyler1, bro.
- I mean, there's a lot fucking Japanese--
(indistinct)
- You obviously have not seen some VTubers
that fucking blow off your ears.
- Oh my God.
- Dude, it's the muscles
combined with it that just adds
to the character building,
that's the real 3D model.
(indistinct)
(laughs)
- I wanna fuck Tyler1.
- You just wanna simp Tyler1.
(indistinct)
(laughs)
- Apes together strong.
Okay, and as well like
I think there's a...
I don't know if this is just me, right?
But it's the reason why I can't
like enjoy certain things.
Okay, I wanna make this very clear
before people get angry at
me because I know people do.
Because I'm like,
kind of doesn't like all the
live kind of hates all this.
I'm interested in other aspects.
And I think blindly just being like, yeah,
I fucking love this thing
is fucking boring.
We wanna have a discussion here.
- Yeah, of course.
- It's a Japanese
company, right, Hololive?
- Yeah.
- Let's be honest.
I'm pretty curious about that cop.
I wanna know what it is.
I wanna know what that contract is like
'cause I guarantee that it is
skewed towards the Japanese.
- Yeah it's probably like
machinima quality right?
- I'm betting it's a Machinima Com.
Yeah, we're talking like,
I would be genuinely surprised
if the creator was getting 30% or more.
If they were getting more than 20%,
I would probably call bullshit.
- Right?
- I think they're getting
anywhere between 20 and 10%.
Again, this is just speculation, like,
I just know--
- It's a very big possibility.
- 'Cause you've got approached
by a Japanese YouTube agency before right?
- Many times, yeah.
- And they were offering similar costs.
- Absolutely garbage.
- Like what was the lowest
one you've received?
- The lowest one I received was 70/30.
But 70 to the company, 30 to me.
- That's how it is.
But you were already
established at that point
which is disgusting.
- Yeah, it's ridiculous.
I think I had like,
almost 2 million subs.
It was it was not that long
ago, sometime last year.
- It's really rare for an...
Especially if you're
an established talent.
- Yeah, right.
- So this is this the kind of numbers
that you were probably getting
pitched by Japanese company
who realized you were established.
- Yeah.
- Can you imagine when
you're not established?
- Yeah.
- Like what numbers they're
going to be pitching you?
- All right.
- And I know,
I know him likes to do that, right?
'Cause it's like, would
you focus on the character,
the entertainer, they're
having fun, they like it.
And it's like, when you're new,
you don't know what's good.
Like, I've spoken to many YouTubers,
who I have personally, like, helped
with deals who would
they were getting paid
like $1,000 for like
sponsorship (indistinct)
10 times that, right?
Just because they're happy with the deal
doesn't make it okay.
- Yeah.
- Like, I wonder if...
Again, it could be a totally fair deal.
I don't know.
I just, I would like to know,
just 'cause it makes me worried.
- Well, I guess this goes into like,
just the darker side of
idol industry period.
- 'Cause it's not only a Japanese company,
it's a Japanese idol company.
And we (indistinct)
- That shit is fucked yeah.
- And I'm interested to see,
we'll never find out.
But I would love to know the
rules of that they're under.
- Well, I don't know
because I feel like with--
- I'd like to think it's modern.
- Yeah, I would also like
to think it's modern.
(indistinct)
- I mean, this is all speculation
so none of us know what kind of deal
the talent has going on.
- It could be completely fucking wrong
and yeah to complete(indistinct)
I fully apologize for that if I am.
I'm just going off base off
experience and what I know.
- You're just playing devil's advocate.
- Yeah.
I mean, get on with what you're saying.
- Yeah, because it feels like to me
just part of the reason
that Hololive rose up
so much in the beginning
was because compared to
other let's say idol agencies
and idol companies,
it's like part of it was that
they just kinda let the girls
do whatever the fuck they want
with less restrictions.
I mean like most idol companies
don't allow girls to fucking swear
or like tell other girls
are gonna piss on each other
which is like one of
one of like (indistinct)
(indistinct)
- The reason the Hololive
expanded so much in our community
was just how much they
were allowed to shitpost
and how much free--
- Yeah, but I wonder if there's somebody
at the charge of it, who's like,
alright, let them shitpost
and we'll keep the profit.
(laughs)
- This episode of Trash Taste
is sponsored by Skillshare.
- [Connor] Skillshare is an
online learning community
with thousands of inspiring classes
for creative and curious people.
Explore new skills,
deepen existing passions
and get lost in creativity.
- [Garnt] Skillshare offers
membership with meaning,
with so much to explore
real projects to create
and the support of fellow creatives.
Skillshare empowers you
to accomplish real growth.
Skillshare offers creative classes
designed for real life
and all the circumstances
that come with it.
These lessons can help you
stay inspired, express yourself
and introduce yourself to
a community of millions.
At a time when so many
important conversations
are happening in our world,
your voice is more essential than ever.
So explore classes to
unlock your creativity
for social good.
- So one of the classes that I took
was the Adobe Photoshop
CC-Essentials Training Course
by Daniel Scott, an
Adobe certified trainer.
My thumbnails will ask for so long
and I was sponsored by Skillshare
called like a year or two ago now.
And they gave me membership for a year
and I used it to get better at Photoshop
'cause Photoshop is a fucking nightmare.
- If you wanna be a YouTuber,
there's so many classes on there.
Just improve your content,
including like the
editing software as well.
- Yeah, like if you wanna do
voice acting, for example,
I really highly recommend
learning audition.
And there's tons of ways
to learn that on there.
And it because it is a
complicated software,
but it's great.
I highly recommend it.
- Skillshare is also
incredibly affordable,
especially when compared to pricey
in person classes and workshops.
An annual subscription
is less than $10 a month.
- Explore your creativity
today@skillshare.com/trashtaste
and the first 1000 people to use our link,
will get a free trial of
Skillshare premium membership.
- God damn that's a deal gone.
That is skillshare.com/trashtaste.
So go to the description right now
and go check out Skillshare.
- Thank you to Skillshare
for sponsoring this episode,
back to the video.
- I almost wonder because you have to...
Correct me if I'm wrong,
you have to audition for Hololive, right?
- Yeah.
- And I feel like when these
positions in this company
where it's like you
have to audition for us,
they can kind of use that power
even then to force you
to take a shitty deal.
It's like, it's 90/10% but, you know,
what's 10% when you're nobody,
we can make you into somebody.
- I mean it's also the argument
of if you're signing with the agency,
you're gonna get so much publicity.
Becaus of how massive HoloLive is.
Like with the English
VTubers that this just debut,
every one of them has
like got over 100k subs,
just like before they
even started streaming
and I'm now they're putting in like,
I remember I was watching
Mari stream yesterday
and she was putting in over like 30K
concurrent viewers streaming.
- Yeah.
- And you just don't get that
starting out by yourself as independent.
That's something you grow over years.
- I'd be interested to see
if that keeps up as well.
Yeah, but I agree.
I mean, you could argue that okay,
even if they are getting a bad car,
well, they're getting a free career.
So they should be happy
with what the company gives.
- I'm sure as well with how powerful
and like willing Hololive is
now in these agencies are.
I'm sure that if they
wanna go into like say,
a lot of them are like
aspiring voice actors.
A lot of them are like aspiring
like that kind of stuff.
I'm sure getting into Hololive
is just a quick shortcut to getting to--
- I'm totally open and happy if I'm wrong.
I hope that it's an amazing fucking deal.
'Cause when was is it?
Like Coco had the most, what was it?
- She was like the highest earning
super chat user in the world.
Like since debuting the art school,
I think she'd like earned
over like 800 or $900,000
which is fucking insane.
- And like I hope most
of that's going to her.
Like she deserves that.
She's the one that doing all the work
for building this character.
She deserves that money.
I'm hoping that they get that.
- 'Cause the thing about
especially Hololive talent
is that everyone is extremely talented.
They obviously can hold
a stream really well,
but a lot of it has other other
talents above that as well.
- A lot of them do like a lot of like,
covers and stuff like that.
A lot of them do like singing stuff
and voice acting stuff.
- It's fucking awesome.
- (indistinct) is a fucking
pro Tetris player or something?
- Yeah.
- Morrigan like, she just
released a song the other day.
That's like fucking...
(indistinct)
- She's so talented.
(laughs)
- I'm so proud of her, man.
- God opens up and just
smiles at the lock screen.
I'm so proud of you, honey.
(laughs)
- Move the picture of the
fucking Vtube (indistinct)
(laughs)
Like when Sydney walks in,
fucking change the tab.
(laughs)
It's Sydney (indistinct), I mean, again--
- I'm just trying to like sell them
because I feel like couldn't get
why I don't wanna get into
VTubers until I got into VTubers.
And now it's really fucking entertaining.
I really wanna talk about how...
The reason I'm so obsessed with them
is because it's just a
kind of entertainment
I couldn't find anywhere else.
- Yeah, I agree, it's definitely.
Yeah, I guess 'cause like
when I hear about it,
and all of it, immediately
my mind is like,
I wanna know how this works.
Like that's immediately what I wanna know.
I only have an interesting anything else.
I'm like, this organization
sounds so unique.
Like, I wanna know how all this works.
How do you decide the cuts?
How do you decide what
rules they have and whatnot?
That's so interesting,
- Because I feel like
that's why a lot of people
got like mad at Pokimane
when she debuted her Vtuber--
(indistinct)
- Which I think is fucking dumb
that we're fucking gate keeping people
putting an anime avatar
themselves like, come on guys.
- Gate keeping is already fucking dumb,
let alone this kind of gatekeeping.
- I think what that stems from
is the appeal of Vtubers like Hololive
is completely different
from just a normal stream
like putting an anime avatar above them.
Because like, it's that
character thing I talked about
where people don't view these
people as people what they do,
but they also don't view them
as just a character as well.
- I think it's also
mainstream not mainstream,
our live streaming was was so mainstream,
like tuned into mainstream
especially with Fortnite.
I feel like everyone
fucking live streams now.
You're not special right?
Cool, go and watch Fortnite right?
Because this is something
like you told me this.
- Yeah, I heard from someone at Twitch.
I don't know how accurate this is,
but apparently, if you average
over 10 viewers on Twitch per stream,
you're in the top 10% of Twitch.
- Jesus Christ.
- I hope that's real.
- If it's real, that's fucking crazy.
- 'Cause every single
console can live stream now.
It's so fucking easy.
(indistinct)
- And so easy to like.
It used to be like, you'd
have a fucking beefy boy,
when I'm streaming, right?
So I feel like it was almost...
At least I don't know, correct
me if I'm wrong, right?
That's what it felt like.
It felt like this one thing
that felt kind of unique in streaming
was then mainstream-ified,
then other people coming in.
There's dirty IRL streamers coming in.
- Those dirty normies
coming into my circle.
Taking over my anime girls?
Nah, not today.
(laughs)
- I wish I could filter myself
live, like in my photos.
But I can't, so how about I
just make myself beautiful?
(laughs)
- I'll just remake myself completely.
- Yeah, I get it man, I'm lazy as fuck.
I look ugly as fuck in half
my streams bro, I wanna--
- I mean, hey, man, I'm already prepared
to enjoy a couple of VTube
streams when I get home tonight.
So Joey, I gotta ask,
who are your favorites?
- All right, I'mma head out.
(laughs)
- Okay, so the first one I
checked out was also Coco.
Only because you fucking love her.
- I love Coco.
- And she's fucking great.
I love her.
But then I found (speaks
in foreign language)
- The best(indistinct)
- I've seen so many clips, she's funny.
- She's so fucking funny.
- She's so cute.
She's so fucking cute.
- Oh my God.
- When I head pat her so bad.
- Oh, the head patting.
(laughs)
- I wanna head pat her so bad.
- I wanna reach into the screen
so I can give her a head pat
because she's such a good fucking--
- She's such a (indistinct)
(laughs)
- And then recently I also
got into this other Vtuber,
NiKoma Takorone,
but she's got like the purple...
She's a cat girl with purple hair.
But I fucking love her
because of her voice.
She kind of has like a tomboy-ish voice.
She kinda has like a
Sawashiro Miyuki voice
so a fucking like Celti's voice.
She has that exact type of voice
and I'm weak for that.
- Wait, so if you can
understand both English
and Japanese fluent, which one?
- What do you mean?
Like with VTubes?
Oh, Japanese for sure.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- How come?
- Just 'cause I don't know the...
I don't know, I must say
you've ever say (indistinct)
(laugh drowns out voice of speaker)
- Even in Vtube--
- Joey leaves to an
English speaking country,
God it's just not the fucking (indistinct)
- Drop that shit in Japanese.
(laughs)
(indistinct)
- Can you believe that shit?
- No because I'm very much like Seyu,
I have a Seyu fetish, like a voice fetish.
Like I love my fucking Seyus,
and if there's like one--
- He's a Seyu simp.
- I'm a Seyu simp like, you know,
like anything that's voiced
by like Sawashiro Miyuki or Kana Hanazawa,
I just immediately fucking
love because the voice
and I feel with Vtube, it's
kinda the same, but like...
But that's the thing though,
I found a few Hololives Japanese streamers
who I really liked their voice,
but their personality
wasn't quite right for me,
so it's just kind of finding that
like perfect combination
of voice and personality.
And for me the top two right
now are Korone and Ohaiyu.
- Who should I watch to get into it?
Who would you recommend for me to watch?
I will watch it and I'll come back--
- What kind of like content
are you looking for?
Because there's so much...
Is there a milf VTuber?
(laughs)
(indistinct)
- 'Cause me and Joe you're
playing this fucking arcade game.
It's so fucking cool.
It's like a huge pile of fucking men.
It's so fucking badass
and you have to pick like your wife
who always talks to you
when you tap your card.
- It's like six different
girls that you can choose from.
- I'm like, dude milfs are
always the hottest (indistinct)
- He picked the milf and
I picked the (indistinct)
(laughs)
- Why are you like
masterpiece (indistinct)
(laughs)
- So I lock in the beautiful
older lady and very nice.
And I look on Joey, which one do you...
It's the fucking 10 year old (indistinct)
(mimics voice)
(laughs)
My fucking God--
- No she's a (indistinct)
bro, it's the best. .
- Oh my God, yeah, masterpiece
is the best (indistinct)
(laughs)
- Yeah, we'll leave that
for another episode.
- Too many kid Hentais out there.
- But that what do you enjoy
and streamers, I should say,
it's not just about the character--
- Or the monkey (indistinct)
- Well no, because I didn't
really enjoy watching XQC.
But I love Tyler1 and I feel
like that's so like close
in terms of the kinda energy they have.
- I don't know like, I
definitely do think like,
you're more into the
kind of like buff-like,
yo, let's go kinda guys.
Like you love Tyler1,
Tectone's our boy like--
- Shout out to Tectone.
- Yeah, I feel like the kind
of in the same realm, right?
Of like energy levels.
- I love watching small streamers.
Like be people like four viewers.
- Right.
- Because you always get the most like...
It's like you you get to watch
someone who's live streaming
who doesn't know how to live stream
and in such an endearing way
when you watch like a 10
year old playing Minecraft
and like that talking to the chat
as they've like learned from like ninja.
You know what I mean?
So they're replicating
a big streamers behavior
but like not quite right
and it's really like uncanny.
- From the sound of
that then I don't think
you can get into any Hololive VTuber,
pretty fucking professional.
- They're all big and
they're all professionals.
You might like some
smaller like Indie VTubers.
- Like I saw I saw a few of them
that were like 2D and it
was like 2D fishes moving
and it was really janky and
I was like, oh that's cute.
(laughs)
They didn't have enough money for the 3D.
I don't know I felt bad.
- They just use my face rig and shit.
- It was like yeah like face rig
but it didn't work properly.
I felt really bad
and I'm like, oh man,
but it's really endearing.
Yeah, I really love like
watching viewers with like 20, 30
because they're kind of
getting into the feel of it,
but not quite there.
Big streamers,
Yeah Tyler1 is definitely my favorite,
like even if I didn't
like League of Legends,
I think I just love him,
like back when he was
doing a variety streams,
he was amazing stuff,
like I think the Life of
Tyler1 is one of the--
- Yeah, you showed me.
- Is one of the best fucking
YouTube videos out there.
- That had to be one the greatest streams.
I wish I saw that.
- I wish I was there.
Like if you haven't watched this video
it's basically what he
does like a whole movie,
he reenacts it, like a budget movie.
- That is like one of my
favorite streams of all.
- That's the kind of streams I wanna do.
I wanna do like events.
- Yeah.
- Kind of like I wanna have a stream
where it's like turn up
something dumb is gonna happen.
- Yeah.
- Like please.
Like, I wanna do more--
- Because like the way I see VTubers
it's kind of like variety TV for me
because everyone's doing
something different,
like one of my favorite streamers to watch
because she just does some
really random shit sometimes,
just Akai Haato or (indistinct)
And like what got me into her stuff
is she's just like,
she's just like pure chaos
and degeneracy into one right.
- That sounds good, I like that.
- Yeah.
- So this one time she was playing
like get over it or something.
And like out of nowhere
she just like smells her feet
because they like like
stink or something, right?
And then through that a meme started.
And then what she did right after that.
It's like one of the most current streams
is that she asks her viewers
to send in feet videos
of just like, people doing
like the strangest things with feet.
And then she reviews them
and it's just equally
as hilarious and curse.
- I'm gonna watch that.
- That sounds disgusting,
but really entertaining.
- Yeah.
And another one is that
she starts reviewing her own lewds, right?
- Oh like doujins of her?
- Yeah, yeah, like rule 34.
So she has like several tiers
of like lewdness.
And she posts like this black bar filter
over like the pictures,
so you can kind of see what's going on.
And you're just watching an
anime go review her own lewds.
And I'm like this is paid content.
Why am I even trying?
Like this is content you
cannot find anywhere else.
- That is like more meta than recreated.
- Can you send me a link
to this, I'll watch it.
Maybe I'll come in next week.
And I'll be like, I wanna
take all my opinions back.
(laughs)
- It's amazing.
- Yeah.
And it's just like entertaining.
It's just stuff
that real streamers can't get away with
and then obviously,
you got like people who are
just really good at video games
with an anime avatar.
- But then there are some that
are just fucking horrible at video games,
and they just make it
so fucking entertaining.
Because it takes them like six
hours to complete one level.
And they just constantly they just trying,
they're really just trying and struggling
and that shit is just cute to watch.
- Oh, fair enough.
Okay, man.
I'll give it a shot.
I mean, I do wanna preface again,
because I know some people
can be so fucking salty.
Yeah, I don't wanna...
I don't hate VTubers.
- He just doesn't understand it.
- I haven't gotten into it yet.
And I would like to play devil's advocate.
- I was exactly like this last week.
- Because if it's just the
three of us talking around dicks
and agreeing on something,
it's not gonna be a very fun podcast.
(laughs)
I hate podcasts where like
yeah, you've got a point.
I agree.
And then they also agree.
- Then they nod their
head for two minutes.
- I can't fucking stand it.
- I don't know I just
feel like VTuber content
is the natural progression
to like anyone who really
go into the Waifu culture.
- Yeah.
- Like we, like us.
Like you that's so.
- I mean, I've got I've gotten into it,
but I guess I wonder why I haven't gone
on the off the deep end yet.
- I mean--
- Because you've never stepped in yet.
- I mean, obviously you never went
into the deep end with the Waifu culture,
you just kind of like--
(indistinct)
- Who's your best girl?
Who's your Waifu Connor?
- Yeah.
- No, because this is...
You you can't do...
That's a loaded question.
- If you can't answer
within five seconds then
you don't have a Waifu.
- That's like saying what's
your favorite genocide?
There's no Waifu
someone's gonna be angry like.
(laughs)
- That's the point of Waifus, man,
you can't please anyone.
- I can immediately answer that question.
- Suzuhara.
- Okay.
- Because she's a goat, man.
- Yeah she is, I agree.
- Because I for some reason, I like...
The whole rental girlfriend thing,
sounds so fucking fun.
I would love to do that
job, that sounds fun.
I would love to be in a situation
to test my acting skills--
- Yeah.
- To be someone else's
like, to meet that grandma
and have to cry.
That sounds like fun.
Does that make me psychotic?
- A little bit.
- That's kind of what
you do on your YouTube.
- Basically.
- Yeah,
I mean you just did it
until I fucking series
where you had a bunch of--
- I wasn't that series but I
would love to like actually try
and like fucking pretend
and see like it would be believable.
I don't know why that sounds fun to me.
- Some people will definitely
call that sociopathic.
- Probably that's a little sociopathic.
What was the point of this?
Oh Suzuhara.
(laughs)
I think she's a goat, man.
She's just a goat, man.
- I fucking loves Suzuhara.
- You just made a fucking video about her.
- Yeah.
- The point is genocide is bad.
(laughs)
Okay, when the whole Waifu culture, right?
- Right.
- Is it like a thing where
when I would like I would
fight for my favorite Waifu.
- Yeah.
- I felt like it was a
thing where it was like,
I genuinely like this character.
But I'm putting on an act,
like I don't actually
care about them that much.
Like, I figured that
everyone was the same way.
(indistinct)
- This is why this we're both taken men.
Like I'm getting fucking
married next year.
- Is this cause like your
relationships aren't satisfying.
Like, God I gotta find something else
to just fill that void.
- No, because I see Waifus
in a totally different realm
than I see real people.
because I think like--
(laughs)
- It has to be stated.
(indistinct)
I think it does.
- I think people some people are like
when they say, your 2D is better than 3D.
Most people just say it is a gag.
(indistinct)
- I've met some people
who are legitimately like,
nah, fuck 3D women, 2D is the way to go.
(indistinct)
- Yeah, exactly.
But we don't like that.
We just say that as a fucking gag.
- You've had your fill of the 3D
you're not satisfied.
- I like the idea of like,
the Waifus or some of the Waifus.
- What's the idea?
- The idea that you can simp for them,
but there's no actual
repercussions for the simping.
- I hate that the word
simp has been invented.
Because now it just it replaces all nuance
of like explaining the feeling.
- But here's the thing,
you can simp for an actual real person,
but you can't see...
(laughs)
But you can't simp for an anime character.
Just that's just not how it works.
But I think some people
just tend to think like,
yeah, I can simp an anime character.
But you can't.
They're not even real.
- You can't simp if they don't exist.
- I guess like,
I don't know why I just seemed,
like I was under the impression
that everyone was like,
pretending to act like to
feel this strongly about it.
- No, I'm sure there are some people.
- I thought that we were all just like,
yeah, I'll kill you for them,
I didn't think anyone actually
was like serious about that.
- No, I mean, I'm not serious about that.
I mean, that's that's
part of the fun of it.
- We all agree that it's like--
(indistinct)
- Did you think we won?
- Wait, on what side?
- Did you think we--
- Did you honestly think
that if you said like,
oh yeah Shinobu is shit
that I would come out
after you with a fucking knife.
(laughs)
- That's what you just said.
I was under the impression
that everyone was like,
we're all pretending
to feel this strongly.
- We are serious but we're not like,
I will fucking commit genocide.
- It's not pretending because--
- You feel strongly,
but it's not genuinely a strong emotion.
- No.
- I feel strongly about
a fictional character.
- About the act your putting on.
- Yeah, we're committed to the media.
- It's an act, right?
Like this is what I'm saying.
Like, I feel like I've met some people
who can't turn that shit off
and they don't know if it's an act.
- That's the thing, we can turn it off.
(laughs)
No, we can turn it off.
But that's because we have a brightness
and we can turn it off.
Some people can't turn it off.
- Like you know how people think like,
everyone just agrees the moon
landing didn't happen right?
It's like that this is
actually a conspiracy theory.
I was like, we all agree
that we're acting right?
When we talk about these Waifu.
This is actually a conspiracy theory,
where no one actually
feels strongly about it.
- It's like some American psycho shit.
- It's like what define feel strongly?
- Yeah, right.
- What do you mean by feel strongly?
- You would never get
upset, like genuinely upset.
Like, I'm talking like,
like crying over sanctity
with a fictional character.
- Some people will though.
- Some people will.
- I mean, this is not
to do with the story.
Like this is like stuff to do with like,
outside emotions that you're bringing in.
- No some people will.
- Why?
- We're not that people.
- What you're describing
is exactly the same way as people who shit
on your favorite anime.
You know what I mean?
Like, you've seen the reactions
where if you shit on some anime,
people gonna like react strongly to that.
- The episode hasn't gone live yet.
Where we shit on the fandoms
but I'm sure we'll see.
- You've seen the smear campaign
that went against like me when I said
that fairy tale was shit, right?
- It wasn't a smear campaign.
- It was a smear campaign.
- Why I'm i still getting hate?
- They were like defend fairy tale
from the anime man, I'm like,
I'm not the only person
who said that fairy tale shit.
But that's the thing.
There are varying degrees.
- Do you think that that the whole like,
simping over the Waifu and stuff
is just the extension of the show?
And the like of the show?
- It's kind of the same
emotional attachments.
- Yeah.
- As the as the resident Waifuologist,
I just made that title up.
- Really, I would never guessed that,
you really didn't have to clarify that.
- I've always found Waifu culture
like super fascinating,
also because like I love it.
- 'Cause it's like an
act that everyone agrees
to just play along with.
- Yeah, but at what point is...
Here's what's interesting.
At what point is like the attachment
you feel towards a Waifu?
At what point do we all agree
that it becomes unhealthy, right?
Because like to me, I can...
To me, I can clearly separate my love
towards a fictional character.
My love towards like real people,
because I can safely say that,
some of like, my favorite Waifus,
they would be fucking
assholes if they existed
in real life.
(laughs)
Like, my God.
- That's what you get for liking Syndra?
- Imagine having a real life Syndra
who fucking hits you
for like, the stupidest shit?
- Which is why
I don't understand about people who say
that Syndra is I mean,
I can't really speak much
cause mine is the same.
But like, at least my Waifu doesn't like
to hit people,
like for no fucking reason, right?
Your Waifu hits people
for no fucking reason.
- These men are disgusting
as if it's like, man,
if she was real, what would she do to me?
(laughs)
'Cause it's weird, right?
Because no one defined the rules
on how to know act about or talk about it,
but everyone just kind
of had this agreement,
but that we're gonna act and all engage
in a way like just like
it's a sports team.
- Yeah, just like a common sense thing--
- But some people have taken it too far.
- There's always gonna be
people who take it to far right?
- It's like fantasy football.
Some people just take it a little too far
and a little too seriously,
even though they know it doesn't exist.
- Yeah, well,
it's like when people like give shit
to the team that like, you motherfucker,
I have $10 on this fucking
game, why don't you go?
- Yeah, like cause I would say,
it's all about the suspension
of disbelief right.
There's so many Waifus that work
simply because they are anime characters.
- Yeah.
- And that's that's what
really works into hey,
I can really fucking love this character
and what she represents
but there's no fucking way
that she exists in real life
and I could be with someone like that.
- That's the exact reason why
I'm okay with maid characters
but I can't stand maid cafes, like that--
- My fucking God, going into a maid cafe
is the cringiest shit--
- It's so cringy.
- I have ever been to.
- It is extremely cringy
and I just don't understand.
Like, I don't mind the whole
like ghosting someone thing
like if it's a fucking fictional
2D character on my screen.
But then when I went into a maid cafe
and a real life woman said that to me
in the exact same way,
I was like, please stop.
- Yeah, and I remember like peak mid 2000s
like cringe culture was all about like,
seeing people act like anime
characters in real life
and I still like, to this
day, I still fucking cringe--
- It doesn't translate.
- Whenever someone tries to
act like an anime character.
And that's whether it's
a fucking Western fan,
or is someone Japanese and it never gets.
- It could be the cutest Japanese girl,
it's still cringe.
- I think also being
British and Australia where
I think we like our social rules
are a lot different to Japan.
- Yeah.
- Just anything like that,
it's just instinctively uncomfortable.
- Yeah.
- Where you're putting on an act
and putting me above you.
- Yeah.
- I think in real life.
I think most people don't like it
when people pretend to be
anything other than a human.
- Right.
- I turn into you when you view Youtubers,
whenever like someone acts
like an anime character,
I'm just like, please
act like a human being,
I know your not an anime character.
- Like you put a fucking 3D model.
Let's go.
- That's it, put a 2D avatar.
- Is it the eye contact?
Is it that they have eyes?
You can see their eyes
and you can see the fuck it's
like death in their eyes.
Please stop.
I can see it in your eyes.
This is uncomfortable for both of us.
- Yeah.
Because every time I
walk into a maid cafe,
I know they're not doing it
because that's what they
really are like, right?
- No because when you're a VTuber,
there's a screen there is a screen--
- That's the barrier.
- You can't you cannot
physically interact with them.
You know what I mean?
- As as a British person,
I get uncomfortable when people smile.
Like when McDonald's employees smile.
Like that's how much I
do not want you to act.
You should not be happy
working at McDonald's.
I worked in McDonald's.
And if you're smiling,
I'm like you don't get
paid enough to smile.
Don't smile.
- It's like saying
that your favorite animal is a lion
and you really enjoy
watching lions at a zoo
because it's from a distance.
(laughs)
But if you're in the cage
with an actual lion, you're like,
I don't wanna get in,
I don't wanna be here.
- There's potential death there.
In McDonald's, when I'm there
and they look at me and they smile at me
asking for my order I'm like,
this is a lie.
You're not happy about receiving my order.
I know you're not, don't pretend.
'Cause it's even that
that level of fakeness
is uncomfortable for me,
especially in the UK right?
You'll never see a fucking
McDonald's employee smile
and when they do, like stop that,
I'm ordering--
- Yeah.
- Stop smiling right now.
- It's like watching a
Youtuber be really nice
when you know they're
an asshole in real life.
- Yeah.
- Just stop man.
(indistinct)
- Yeah, I don't know, I think it's like,
again with maid cultures, we don't like it
when people are fake to us.
And when we know they're being fake to us.
And I guess that's why YouTubers
and livestreamers have
done well for for so long
because it's poised as this real thing.
It's a genuine thing and there
are some people out there
who are and there are
also people out there
who most definitely aren't.
- Which is why like I never understood
like real Japanese idol culture in Japan.
Because the one thing I didn't understand
was this idea that
these real human beings,
needed to be perfect,
that is the Japanese culture.
If they're anything but perfect,
they kept fucking destroyed.
- They need to be pure.
More pure than anyone can be.
- Their whole life is over.
- To me that that is that is
the unhealthy side of things.
- Stochastic as fuck.
- Because it's when you are
imbuing fictional aspects
to real people
and you expect real people to
act like fictional characters.
The reason Waifus work
is because they can be perfect
or they it's the idea
of them that is perfect.
- I remember one fucking
great Japanese meme
that came out of about years
ago like this started on Twitch
but there was a thread
of some person fucking critiquing idols
and the idol culture
and that kind of shit.
And there was this one reply
of this like absolute simp for idols,
who was like, idols don't poop.
(laughs)
They don't poop.
They're so pure
that they don't even poop.
- Isn't that something like
North Korea says about Kim Jong.
- He doesn't poop.
It's just rainbows but yeah.
- No, he doesn't waste, there's no waste.
- There's no waste.
- It's converted into cause
he's a perfect a human being.
It all gets converted to energy.
- And then that turned into a meme
where it's like if something is so pure,
they just like yeah, they don't poop.
Yeah, they don't poo.
Idols don't poop, they're
perfect in every sense.
- They shit rainbows.
- Yeah, they shit rainbows.
- I'll eat their shit, why not?
- It's like a lion.
(laughs)
Already cloudy, it's like Mike was out.
I don't know, oh my God it's hard
because there's so many...
I guess because VTubers have
gotten in that perfect spot
where it's like it is
done the everything right
that kind of goes against
the rules of other things
that would make them comfortable.
- I mean, I find it fucking amazing
how just how quickly VTubers have exploded
because I remember when Kizuna Ai debuted,
like she started a massive
fucking wave of Japanese VTubers.
And nobody here gave a shit at all.
- Right, yeah.
- Some people do like
Kizuna Ai but I think--
- I feel like it was Kizuna Ai,
and like there was like
a top three, I think.
- Yeah, it was Kaguya Luna and like Siro,
i think were the top three.
They had the most attention
and then there was like a BTA of like,
like kind of smaller like 100K,
and then the CT was like,
actual 1000s, 10s of 1000s.
- But like I feel like
we're just on the cusp
of like something similar happening
to the English speaking culture.
- I'm excited because it's fun
because I feel like it could
either be like you said like
something giant could comment
really establish itself
or it could be a flash in the pan.
- I think it's a little
bit different though
than the the Vtubers, Youtubers are,
because with the Vtuber, Youtubers side
there was this like big three
or like there was a
couple of really big faces
that were kind of pulling
the entire community.
- I feel that will happen there.
- Yeah, but I feel that
with like the live stream
is like with Hololive and Ninjisanji.
Everybody's kind of at
the top at the same time,
like the entire community
is growing at once.
It's not so much one
person leading the way.
- It will eventually level out there.
This video is also sponsored by Ej Anime.
- And the same with Japan.
(laughs)
- Fuck you Connor.
- You got this time.
- Ej Anime store is Kamikaze
official anime merge store
and once again today they have brought us
a collection of some of
the newest anime figurines
that you can get only on Ej Anime store.
- So the first one
that we have at the front there
is echidnas from the new
Re:Zero anime season.
This is the echidnas tea party version.
- The girl who just
destroyed every other girl
by being introduced in season two.
Sorry Beatrice, I'm
simping over echidnas now.
- This man changes his mind quicker
than the wind changes direction.
- But the great thing about this figure
is that it includes a
letter written by the author
of the original Re:Zero
light novel series.
now that's key topic
as an exclusive bonus.
- We also have the Angel Beats figure
in the front which is
the Kanade Tachibana.
Its keys 20th anniversary
and this is the gothic Lolita version.
The special edition includes
an A4 acrylic standard
and exclusive bonus.
- And we also got the Strike
the Bloods Yukina Himaragi
tropical wedding version.
- Tropical wedding.
I actually do like the the ribbon,
like kind of fluttering
around in the dress
and everything it's got
a lot of movement to it.
- This is celebrating the completion
of the original Strike the
Blood light novel series.
- I actually can't believe
I know they've been
going on for that long.
- I know right.
- I swear it started in like mid 2000s.
- I remember seeing like anytime
there's a new Strike the Bloods
or like Strike Witches anime series.
I'm like,
man, they're still going on?
Is this still going on, seriously?
- But wait, does it come
with a special item?
- Yes, this special sale
includes a big tapestry
of the original created illustration
that inspired this figure.
- Well, the one I wanna talk about
is this one at the back here,
which is the Konosuba figure
and it's a double figurine of Iris
and Megumin.
- I will say this figure is
heavily pushing monetization
on our channel.
Thank you very much.
But yeah, this is the Konosuba continued
and explosion on this wonderful wall.
Irisin Megumin lightened
little thief version.
And this set includes a
larger rubber play mat
as an exclusive bonus.
- A play mat?
- Yeah, like the stuff that
you can play like yogioh on.
- I thought it was like the kids
when they have like the car.
(laughs)
- I mean if my kid played all that,
I'll be like, my man.
- And finally, we have
the Sword online figure.
- Joey's favorite anime.
- I love it.
- This is the action of
midsummer sparkle bride version.
- Okay, as much as I don't rate the show,
I wanna do long lesson
online is it's figurines,
like that's nice.
That's a nice figure, I would get that.
- Celebrating the 10th anniversary
of the original light novel series,
we introduce astronaut
running along the beach
in a wedding inspired bikini
from the catacomb
collection figure series.
This figure includes a big tapestry
of the original creative illustration
that inspired the figure
as an exclusive bonus.
- Lots of exclusive bonuses
only at Ej Anime store.
- So yes, if you liked
any of the figures--
- No, if you love these figures,
which we know you did.
- That's right, my bad man.
- Sorry if you loved any of these figures,
then you go to Ej Anime store.
- Man.
- God fucking.
- E-J-animestore.com.
- Link's in the description.
- They're constantly adding
new stuff to the store.
So go and keep checking it out.
- Thank you Ej Anime store
for sponsoring this episode.
- Back to the video.
Yeah, I feel like we're in a cusp
of like just a new genre
being like birthed.
- I hope so.
- Like cause I wouldn't be surprised
if like in a year or something,
Twitch has a VTuber category on stream.
- That'd be cool.
- I mean, that's that's
kind of what I feel like
we're about to experience,
because it's weird that
it's didn't this past week,
where it's just gone from
this kind of cult following to
everyone kind of talking about it
and livestream circuit now.
- I hope so.
I mean, I'm always down for anything
that like spices up a little bit.
I feel like live streaming has
been a bit stale for a while.
And even if I'm not into it right now,
I'm sure there's gonna be
someone I like and again,
the ones I have seen I've rather enjoyed,
just haven't gotten into it to the point
where I feel very strongly about someone.
- [Joey] All right.
- Yeah, I don't know.
- I mean, I just like people's content.
That's basically how I see.
I see VTubers.
People are gonna make
the simp memes whatever,
you're gonna make it anyway.
(laughs)
But I respect them the same way
I respect any other content creator
on YouTube or any streamer on Twitch.
- Because they like if you honestly
if you take away the whole
like anime girl facade away,
they just genuinely really
fucking good entertainers.
- Dude if Dior's voice actor
became a Vtuber, it's all over,
now I'm gonna simp.
- When we get like officially
established voice actors
to do vtubing, man it's over.
- It's gonna happen
- They gotta get (indistinct)
- One thing I do find funny though,
is that I know several people like myself,
who like we're very big
anime fans obviously,
who now watch way less anime,
just because vtubing has (indistinct)
- It's like Friendship Ended With Anime,
New Best Friend, Hololive.
- It's like that Toy Story meme,
like, I need to get rid of the toy.
I don't wanna play with you anymore.
(laughs)
- Honestly though, like just this weekend
I had so many plans
and they were just completely ruined
by the fact that I got into Hololive.
- I'm just gonna masturbate.
- Had to cross all those out.
- Because I feel like it's
just been the perfect storm
of 2020 being one of...
I think we can all agree 2020
has been one of like the
weakest years of anime
in quite a while.
That's not just the fault
of the anime coming out.
Obviously there's the
entire world situation,
but it's also that--
- Nothing's really like,
excited everybody unanimously.
There's been, series like, right to go for
and that kind of stuff who have like,
some people have gotten excited about it.
But there hasn't been that one show
that everyone's like, yes, let's go.
- Yeah, I mean, other than
Re:Zero and Rent a Girlfriend
and maybe like, I don't know,
what the fuck that Demon
fucking school thing?
- Demon school.
(indistinct)
(laughs)
- I would even say that.
I've seen a lot less hype
around these big shows,
which are the biggest right now,
than I would say in other years.
- I wonder if it's also a mixture of like,
a great pretender being kind of scattered.
And all the big Netflix shows
kind of being thrown out there,
kind of not really
allowing much discussion,
in a way that, okay, if
there's less discussion
going on on social media,
because less people are
watching in the same way.
I guess it makes it way easier to then
get behind something like
Hololive where it's live,
and the memes can be shared instantly.
- I mean, I feel like just VTubers
are the hot thing right now.
And it's just what's on
everyone's feed right now.
- Right, that's why I'm really interested
to see how it will level out.
I don't know if it will,
if it will keep growing up.
- I hope so.
- I mean, I hope so, more interesting.
- Speaking of like Netflix
anime and everything,
like this weekend, I haven't
done this in a while.
But I watched an entire
show in like one day.
- Get out of here.
- What is this 2013?
- It's so weird.
- What show was it?
- It's Dorohedoro.
- Yeah, I've watched that too.
- Yeah fucking awesome.
- So it's beem a while, like I
started watching a while ago,
completely forgot what happened.
- It's amazing right?
(laughs)
- Here's the thing--
- I've never lost a job
so quick in my life.
- I just like the way you
said that so casually,
it's like it's amazing right?
- And I just said so.
I mean, okay, here's the thing.
I did like it.
But it's one of these things
that makes me hate
being like an anime fan.
Because it's one of those--
- I simp over it.
- I have this experience so often, right?
So you have you have
this 13 episode series.
It's got so much potential.
It has a really interesting world.
It has really cool characters.
And then just as you start to
get invested in everything,
nothing really happens.
- That's why you read the Manga, bruh.
- That was Dorohedoro for me.
Because I really love the world.
It's one of the most interesting worlds
I've seen in a while.
Like the whole, it's so fucking brutal.
And the magic system is
really weird as well.
It's a really--
- It's unconventional,
it's very unconventional.
It's kind of like Mad
Max timed psychopaths
or something along those lines.
- Does something have to happen?
'Cause we're probably gonna
get a season two probably.
- That's no guarantee.
Especially that's that's the thing, right?
That's the thing about being an anime fan.
With so many shows, you're
just in fucking limbo.
You're like,
just tell me if I'm
gonna get another season
or tell me if I'm not.
I just wanna know, should I just go ahead
and binge the Manga or should I wait?
- With Dorohedoro you should.
- To be fair Netflix has been pretty good
with making season two's for that.
- We've got a lot better recently.
But yeah, like I was
really enjoying myself
with Dorohedoro,
but it just ended and I
was just feeling like--
- Empty inside.
- I can't remember exactly what happened.
- That's exactly it.
- It's been like, since
we started the podcast
when I watched this.
- Yeah.
- But I remember.
- That's two months.
- That's not two months.
- No, it came out way earlier than that.
- It's like four months
ago I watched that shit.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- We didn't start this
podcast like four months ago.
- It's like 20 weeks ago.
- Yeah.
- No fucking way.
- This is episode 18, Garnt.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- So I watched--
- What the fuck is 2020, man?
I was like this is episode five right?
We've been on trash day
for like two months.
- Your like a fucking comatose
patient on the podcast.
Oh my God, I watched it like then
and I remember being really fucking happy
that it felt so fucking refreshing.
It was like a fucking glass of
orange juice in the morning,
I was like, damn, that's nice.
- Yeah, the Manga especially.
- I read a few of the
chapters of the Manga
where it left off and
I was like, holy shit.
- Hiya Sedekyu's odd,
it's just fucking insane.
- I felt fine being like you know what?
I can tell the story isn't
getting to the best bits
and that's totally fine.
Like I get it.
- It's nowhere near
getting to the best bits.
- It's fine.
- I mean, it's fine.
It's just annoying, right?
Because I like experiencing
the best part of stories.
I like seeing stories go from like,
at least hits one kind of climax
because I feel like--
- There was Attack on Titan season two.
That's what it was.
- My problem with Dorohedoro
was that I can't point to
a single part to be like,
this is a huge climax happening right now.
- It doesn't have to have that though.
Like literally the slice
of life fucking like literally
just named slice alive.
Like nothing climatic ever happens.
- I feel that the thing,
I feel the reason why Dorohedoro
was so unique in that sense
is because it poses this incredible world
and these incredible characters
and yet they really take
their time to like--
- And they don't mind you
showing you the characters
you might not be interested in.
- Yeah, because eventually
they will become interesting
and it's a slowly building up world.
- I didn't give a shit about.
- No, i can say it's perfectly,
it just didn't feel like a season.
Yeah, it felt like,
alright, we've just run out of time.
Let's just cut the season off basically.
Like with most anime seasons,
you have some kind of climax,
you have a season finale.
This didn't really feel
like a season finale.
You just kind of just ended.
- I don't know,
sometimes I feel like I don't need that.
Like sometimes the ride is
better than the destination.
You know what I mean?
- I want a complete package with my story.
- Well because I feel the
same thing kind of happened
with Beastars as well.
- Yeah Beastars didn't end satisfyingly.
- There wasn't really-
- No, that had a climax.
- Where was the climax?
- The stage performance?
- No, not just the safe performance,
but they fucked when he...
I can't say this without
going into spoilers.
- You can spoil it,
just say spoiler alert.
- But when he saved her,
that was pretty climactic.
That was the end of a story.
- Dorohedoro had equivalents of that.
When he bled out his magic juice.
And they had to get it back or something.
I can't remember what happened.
- Something like that yeah.
- I remember just being like
fucking hyped, I don't know.
Not everything like needs to
have a neat package, Garnt.
- Yes, it does.
- No it doesn't.
- Yes it does.
- No it doesn't, man.
- Literally The Lord of the Rings movie
like it's a mess bro.
- Because I think at least at the end
of the Lord of the Rings movie,
you still have some kind of closure,
but it's like, that was
that was a cool story.
- I swear like what the fuck happens
in the second Lord of the
Rings film at the end?
- There's two towers.
That's the only thing I remember.
- There was that climactic
battle at the end of two towers.
- That wasn't the end of it though.
- What you mean it wasn't the end of it?
That was the end of the battle.
- Yeah, the end of the battle,
not the end of the movie.
- Imagine if they just stopped mid battle.
- Dorohedoro did not do
that, we didn't get like a...
We didn't we didn't get like a ticket.
- Because we didn't even
get the big climactic battle
in Dorohedoro.
- Okay, Megalo Box was
basically that, right?
No, it was a very nice,
it was a cool story had
a very nice package.
And that was shit, right?
- What the fucking...
No, Megalo Box is great,
what are you talking about?
- It was boring bro.
- Megalo Box was like,
let's take ping pong and put
it in like a boxing setting.
(laughs)
What didn't you like about Megalo Box?
- No, I love mega blocks
in the first viewing,
I just said mega blocks.
(laughs)
I love Megalo Box.
I enjoyed it.
But at the same time,
I'm like the story was just
kind of like, alright, cool.
I mean, I knew what was gonna happen.
It was so fucking obvious.
Like, it was just kind of like, all right.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm not
saying that Megalo Box
was the greatest animates
come out of that year.
- But people are like it's
the fucking great,
like people are genuinely
upset that it wasn't anime
of the year, right?
- I mean, it wasn't that good.
I would say I felt more complete.
I mean,
I definitely felt more
complete watching Megalo Box--
- But I think Dorohedoro was better than
that Megalo Box for me.
- I mean, for me,
like at the moment.
Yeah, I can see that Dorohedoro
definitely had more potential
to be good than Megalo Box.
I'm just saying that it
didn't get near that point.
It didn't fucking get near that point.
And I wanted something...
I wanted a moment I could
think back to Dorohedoro
and be like, that was a great show.
- But to me--
- The baseball.
(laughs)
Where they had like the
giant cockroach join them
to play baseball.
This is so fucking dumb, but I love it.
- By the way,
if you're wondering why
I'm not heavily involved
is because I read all the Manga
and I'm completely satisfied with this.
- Yeah, I'm sure the Manga is amazing.
- Yeah, I didn't even watch
the anime 'cause I'm--
- Joey's that guy.
- Yeah I'm just that guy.
- Joey is a fucking smug cunt.
- I'm like, you peasants (indistinct)
- Joey is there when fucking
Jesus is on the cross,
Joey's like God, you should
see what happens next,
you guys won't believe it.
(laughs)
- I'm the guy in the cinema
who likes mouths what they
say as it's happening.
- Just wait till we get to the cave.
Yeah, you gotta keep your eye on the cave.
You guys thought that
was insignificant bro.
- I'm not saying he's
gonna come back but yeah.
(laughs)
- He's gonna revive.
(indistinct)
- I hate those fucking Manga fans.
- God, he's such a smug cunt.
- Like, you like that character, okay.
- Have fun while it last?
- Yeah, you might not wanna get into it,
just like forget what I'm
saying, it means nothing.
Just don't get into that character.
- I hate it though when
you have that friend
who wants to know the like,
is anything gonna happen to them?
I'm like, don't ask me that.
- I'm absolutely that guy
that's like, oh you'll see.
- I hate it when people tell me like,
I'm like, yeah I've got these three parts
that's like, part four's the best.
I'm like don't fucking tell
me what part is the best,
I wanna have my own opinion.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, I just wanna go into like a series
with like zero expectations
because even if I hear something like,
this part is fucking amazing,
like I don't wanna know
this part is amazing.
I just wanna like experience
the fact that it's amazing
instead of like hyping it up
because then I have
like expectations to me,
and I don't want expectations to me
- To fuck Joey over here.
As Joey just started
watching Demon Slayer.
- Yeah, finally.
- The Anime Man watching
Demon Slayer in 2020.
- I was that bored.
He's like, all right.
- You haven't watched the
animation of the decade.
- Animation of the decade.
- The reason why I watched Demon Slayer...
Excuse me but...
The reason why I watched Demon Slayer
was because I was not watching it,
but then suddenly on Twitter,
dude episode 19, it was insane bro.
You won't believe it bro
the animation made my fucking
gave birth to my child bro.
Fixed all of my age (indistinct)
(laughs)
- It was like I've never seen...
This is like the level of hype
that must have been there for Jesus
is like fucking resurrection bro.
I've never seen so much hype
for something in my life.
- I think that was the first time
I've ever seen an anime
trending on Twitter.
- Like fucking ninja was
like bruh I'm an anime fan
whole time fucking like.
- Are we just gonna call it that now
the Jesus resurrection now.
(laughs)
- It was the second coming of Jesus.
- I have probably made too
many religious references
this podcast.
I just think if people could
feel strongly about religion.
But anyway, I watched it
and the whole time I was
watching Demon Slayer,
I was unimpressed by everything
because I was like, yes,
I'm waiting for episode 19.
I'm saving my nut for episode 19.
And there was plenty
of really amazing like.
- Saving my nut.
(laughs)
- It's like when you've
watched a porno right?
You're saving your, you
know where the good bit is.
We all do it right, let's
not pretend like we don't,
everyone skips, you know
where the blow jobs starts
and you skip.
- Let's go to literally 10 minutes in
and then let's skip again 20 minutes.
- Okay do you watch the blow jobs in porn?
- No.
- No, you skip past it, right?
So you skip past it and then
they're already in like,
then you've gone too far
because they already fucking fully at it.
Yeah, you wanna get before
they just start that.
- Right.
- That's what it was right.
That's what it was.
- Are you saying that episode 19
was the post blow job.
- It was the post blow
job part of the plan.
It was like the everything else.
It was like you knew it was the blow job
so you're like I'm saving it,
I'm saving the nut, I'm saving it.
You have to save it because
if you get super hyped about
something that happened
and you know better is coming on,
you can't match.
- Yeah, true.
- I'm sorry to the female
viewers who don't watch porn.
- Or the male.
(indistinct)
- We don't discriminate here.
- But what the fuck.
- Yeah so what is your
opinion on Demon Slayer then?
- Okay, so I have--
- It's the blow job of the anime.
- It's an animation of the decade.
So I'm not up to episode 19 yet.
I think I'm right before that.
- Save that nut.
- I'm saving the nut.
- Save the nut.
- But that's I think that's
one of the big reasons
why I decided to not watch
it until much much later
because I didn't want that
hype to sway my opinion.
Of course I mean like,
I'll admit, like,
because it was everyone
was fucking talking
about at the time, right?
It's definitely in the back of my head.
- You were unimpressed with
things because you're expecting
to be impressed.
- Right, because I'm expecting episode 19
to be the one that nut to.
- To be the nut.
- To be the nut, right.
So I'm basically blue balls
for fucking 18 episodes.
I'm just like it's coming,
I've got to hold on.
- It's like a JV
where it's like 15 minutes of buildup.
(laughs)
- It is like but I think
that's why I wanted it to wait
until all the hype was over,
just so that the earliest
stuff doesn't fucking persuade
how I see the actual show.
I want it to just go
into a completely clean.
- And I feel sorry for
anyone who's doing that
with Attack on Titan.
It's like, someday it's
gonna stop being popular.
It's just not.
- It's just not happening, yeah.
But also because the Manga is ending soon,
or I think it's almost
at the end, I don't know.
- I think it has ended.
Yeah, so it has ended.
So I'm like, okay, now
is probably the best time
to actually start watching it
just so that I can probably go
and just read the Manga as well,
because I'm that guy.
So I was just bored.
And I was like, all right
you know what, fuck it.
I'll see what this show is all about.
And it's good.
I enjoy it.
It's great.
It's very--
- It's the cornflakes of
anime, you can't hate it.
Like it's cornflakes.
- It's very inoffensive.
Like, there there is nothing inherently
about the show I dislike
but I just I mean, so far,
I can't fucking stand Zenitsu, I'm sorry,
like he's just he's annoying.
- Who does?
- There are lots of people.
- There are so many people
who simp for Zenitsu
and I'm like why?
He's just fucking annoying.
- I guess 'cause I think a lot of people
can relate to the, yo, hold me back
because if I go set sicko mode,
I unleash my true power, you're done son.
I think a lot of people
can relate to that,
I'm a pussy but--
- [Joey] Yeah.
- When my ultimate self cool
down you better better run bro.
- That's the problem though is right now
is that I don't know if I'm just not
as invested into showing in
characters as most people are
but just like I don't
really care about Zenitsu,
right now, I still don't really
care about Inosuke that much
maybe I'll (indistinct)
- I know people gonna be pissed about me
but like I feel like it is
literally My Hero Academia
with the skin like think about it.
In those case Bakugo.
- Yeah.
- Tanjiro is Deku, Zenitsu
is I don't fucking know.
An amalgamation of
probably some (indistinct)
- Here's the thing Demon Slayer
to me is solid it's just.
- So is My Hero Academia
like it's just another
solid show.
- But to be fair if I can't,
I would rather watch Demon Slayer
than My Hero Academia.
- No same, is there a
tomahawk in Demon Slayer?
That's what I need to know.
- No yeah, I mean the Demon Slayer--
- No that we know of,
Manga reader Manga readers.
- There probably is.
- I just wanna find it
because I feel like Demon
Slayer has just filled
that gap in that was the
beast bleach fan before.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause like you haven't
got to the later episodes
where they basically introduce like--
- A whole 70,000 characters.
- Yeah, we basically have a soul society.
- Yeah, I do admit I'm way more invested
in the world's building of Demon Slayer
than I am in My Hero Academia.
- Yeah.
- There's so much...
I don't know the characters feel,
like the ones that we
don't know much about
seem so much more interesting.
Whereas I don't give a
fuck about (indistinct)
Like I don't think he's fun to watch.
- I didn't even get that far.
- I think it's fucking boring.
- I like for me--
- Human scrotum with powers.
(laughs)
- Like I really really
enjoyed Hero Academia
and then as more seasons came out,
I went from like loving it
to be like, solid.
- For me it's like I watched season one.
And that was like should
I watch season two
and then reflect it on like,
I didn't like season one
enough to go watch season two.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Then people like new season two
is when the tournament ark begins bro.
It's so fucking cool.
- Way to a cool me .
- I'm just like I don't
give a shit about--
- Are you cut up on My
Hero Academia anime?
- Yes, I am.
- Did you like the last
season that just happened?
- No I did not.
- Oh my fucking God.
I was so bored.
- Really?
- Like, I did not think
they built up the overload?
- Overload?
- That's a a good villain.
- Over something the plague doctor.
I didn't think they
built him up very well.
And then the whole...
it was like literally the anime trope
where every single
episode had a flashback.
And then they won the fight
and it's like, for fuck sake.
- That's what I hated about Naruto.
- It's the exact same thing.
- Yeah.
- Like cut back on the fucking flashback.
- Like my my favorite fight in
My Hero Academia to this day
is the first All Might vs Noumu fight
like zero flashbacks.
- That shit was good.
- In season one yeah.
- That to me sold me on the show
and that was like zero flashbacks.
It was just a hero being a hero
and now it's just not...
That was a clean nut.
- It was.
- And like other acts
there have been good points
in other acts but it hasn't taken me back
to the love I felt at that point.
- That's a good point I'll be honest,
I don't think I was as hyped
for the all my verses or for one fight.
Noumu Versus--
- I mean all my verses was just like--
- You knew he was gonna win.
- I mean, that was less about
the fight the fight itself,
which is really fucking boring
because they like, yeah
you had all for one.
All right, a million fucking powers
and he uses the same fucking attacks
five times in a row.
- Literally me in a fighting game.
X, X, X, X, X.
He doesn't have the fucking combo sheet.
How is he supposed to know it?
If you have all these powers,
how the fuck do you know
what combos to gather?
- It's like mashing X and then every now
and then the triangle.
- It's literally like when
you learn the one combo
that seems to be spammable.
- Yeah.
- That's literally all for one.
Like he's case figured out three combos
that seem to work well.
It's like I don't really wanna do that.
Like, I don't think the
bubbles power up will go well
with the photocopy power.
- It's like smash play who
only spams the forward Smash.
This will get the job done.
- I wonder if there
was ever a conversation
where he stole powers people like
but why did you steal that power?
It's like, I stole the power
to be permanently erect.
It's like but why?
Why did you steal that power?
- I'll tell you what it is.
It's like the same syndrome you have
when you're like scrolling on Netflix,
where you just have like
so many fucking powers
and your like fuck yeah
I'll just rewatch the same
thing five times in a row.
- Okay, I'll be honest, right.
I really fucking wanted All
Might to win that fight and die.
- Yeah, I wanted him to die as well.
- I think that would have
been fucking legendary.
- Yeah, top 10 anime deaths.
- I would have said legendary.
- Legendary?
- Yeah, he should have died.
I thought it would have
made like the next ark or so
because he's just kind
of chilling around now.
Which is just kinda like
the boomer who's like,
yeah, I was cool once.
- I love hanging out with these kids.
- I'm sure Manga readers.
I say always with that
omnipotence knowledge and--
- Especially the My Hero.
- That three 360 vision and hindsight.
- I'm fucking one thing
my biggest pet peeve,
is when you have like
a criticism of a show.
That's like up to that point,
and the Manga reader is just like,
(indistinct)
- 10 volumes in, you'll see.
You'll see.
Thank you Joey, thank you for that.
- To me, it felt like hesitation
that he didn't kill All Might.
Because he'd been building up
All Might's frail ass like,
poison ridden body.
- Don't look at me
I don't know what the
fuck you're talking about.
- Come on.
(laughs)
Like he built up how frail
and how he was dying.
Why didn't he kill him there
at the peak right like.
I don't know, to me he should.
- Maybe because he was too
much of a beloved character.
- I think that was
probably he was scared to.
I don't know maybe the
again the Manga readers
forgot why actually the some you know.
- I don't give a shit.
- Definitely that scene
would have definitely
hit me harder if he had died.
- Because it also would
have made endeavors like
when he becomes the hero,
in the next arc,
that would have made
that even more impactful
because he's the only one left now.
Right and he never got to
show All Might that right.
Why are we going on a fucking fanfic
of My Hero Academia.
I wanted him to die.
He shouldn't fucking died, kill All Might.
- Let me rewrite My Hero Academia.
(indistinct)
- This is how it's supposed to be done.
I'm a writer.
- So let let me fix your art.
- Stop getting banned in China.
Let me fix it.
- I'm a writer, hire me Horikoshi.
- I don't know like this stuff like that,
that I don't have fucking
I'm losing interest
in My Hero Academia by the season.
- I am as well.
I didn't think I would
because one thing I was super hyped about
when it first started airing.
And right now I think I
like Black Clover more
than My Hero Academia.
And I didn't--
(indistinct)
Did I just say something blasphemous?
I don't know.
Because--
- How can a man be so brave.
- You have made the Black Clover
fandom extremely happy now.
You've given them validation
where there wasn't.
- Recognition.
- Here's your validation everyone.
But now because I feel
like with Black Clover,
it's just so much fun.
It's just fun.
It's just this is the pure
show and fun I was looking for.
And with My Hero Academia,
I feel like it's trying
to go for greatness.
It's like it's trying to build--
- It's going for the long con.
- It's going for long con.
It's trying to build
up so many great points
and great characters,
but it's just doing a lot of things
that is just not keeping
my interest as well.
Like what the fuck?
Okay, what the fuck was that last arc
in My Hero Academia season four as well
with the villain who
I can't even remember,
the fucking magician
- The British guy basically.
- Yeah.
- He's whole quack
Is that like, he?
What is it like he drinks tea?
- Yeah.
- I don't actually think that's his quack.
But all he does is drink tea.
He can make things into...
He's basically Hisoka.
He makes things into rubber.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
And then he drinks tea.
So that's like,
like that's also his big thing
is that he's like really picky about tea.
And I'm like,
Is this how he like
envisions British people?
Because yes, that's actually true.
- I mean just felt like a filler arc.
That wasn't actually filler.
And I know people are gonna
be mad at me because yeah--
- I'm looking forward to the
comments on this episode.
- They enjoyed the school
festival and everything
but I was just not invested
enough in the side characters
to really give a shit
about the school festival
and the villain was just
fucking weak sources fuck
so I don't give a shit about that.
So that entire arc was just...
I'm gonna forget that one
when season five ends.
- Yeah, I wonder is My
Hero Academia trying
to go for like a 10 year run here
or do you think it's gonna be like--
- I feel with just how successful it is.
I'm sure people have shown it.
Well, because I think
the people have shown
in jump they want a--
- A One Piece replacement.
- No, not so much One Piece replacement
but they want something that will line up
with One Piece for a while
because we've currently had
Demon Slayer just ended,
Haikyu just ended.
- Is One Piece gonna end anytime soon?
- Well, Oda said that it'll
end in the next five years,
but who the fuck, it's Oda.
- In One Piece years that's pretty soon.
- It's One Piece that's really soon,
but it's been gone for like 25 years.
- I'm wondering as a fan
who has been watching My
Hero from the start, right?
How, like, do they really
expect someone to be
into a show for 10 years?
- Yes.
- Yeah, of course.
I've been into One
Piece for over 10 years.
- Yeah.
- I've been into One Piece
for as long as I've read it.
- Like when One Piece ends--
- I think my mom gave up like,
be interested in me after like, eight.
You know what I mean?
- Like, she fucking birthed me.
(laughs)
(indistinct)
- When One Piece ends I'm
gonna cry like nobody.
- No, I'm gonna fucking
cry when One Piece ends.
- 'Cause that's like a
huge part of my life.
That's just gone.
Yeah, it's just like,
your pet dying or something.
- I guess I did watch like Game of Thrones
for like, 10 years.
- 10 years?
Well it's eight seasons, right,
but they took like, two years and last--
- Yeah, that's true.
- I mean, think about--
- And that was the worst ending
I've ever had in my life.
- I mean think about the amount
of people who fucking cried
when Harry Potter ended.
And that show had been going off...
Well, not show but like that book series
had been going on for
like fuck knows how long.
- True, I guess I underestimate,
I guess when you say be
interested in this for 10 years.
It sounds hard.
But then in real life,
it's very much not like that.
So like every day you're like, I'm caring.
- Yeah.
- I saw on Twitter.
There's actually some
people who are like yeah,
I fucking love One Piece ever.
- Yeah, but that's their
only personality trait, right.
(laughs)
- Your Tinder profile, I like One Piece.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
It's like, we're meant to be.
- It was so weird.
like seeing even something like Naruto
seeing the characters grow up
and I'm like kind of like
growing up with the characters.
(indistinct)
I shit on Boruto and everything
but some of those first few episodes
where you see Naruto as a
dad, you see Sasuke as a dad
and you're like--
- Well, the same thing happened
with fucking Avatar The
Last Airbender ended right.
and then the first
episode on Korra was like,
oh my God, Katara is old now.
But then after the first episode,
I was like, alright, I don't fucking care.
- I love Korra.
- I thought Korra was kind of mean.
- You fucking love that word.
I left it at four seasons.
Was it four seasons?
- Of Korra?
No, I think it was three.
- I lived all of it.
People had the complaints,
but I was like, okay.
- Okay, because I never grew up
on Avatar the Last Airbender.
- Me neither.
- Yeah, I only just recently watched it
like in the last couple of years.
- Yeah, me too.
- Avatar is fucking amazing.
- I actually still haven't seen.
- Okay, it's fuck.
I completely understand the hype now
because it's fucking great.
- But then I was Korra and I
was like, this doesn't hit.
This doesn't hit different.
- It's like a great anime kind of feel.
But also has that comfort of
a Saturday morning cartoon.
It's really like in a sweet spot.
- The jokes are like very campy.
- I don't think I've ever heard you talk
about something as endearing
as you just talked about.
- So comfortable about
really like takes you,
it's like how you felt.
I imagined when I say like,
imagine when you were
trading Yu-Gi-Oh cards
with your friends.
Like, man that was fun, wasn't it?
- I can totally understand why people
just isn't into it today
as they were back then.
- It really is like, encapsulated
and captured it like like
time capsule of like,
just that feeling.
Yeah, when you watch it,
you can't help but get that feeling.
- Yeah.
- Gentlemen, we all know a
VPN protects all privacy.
No one's doubting that.
And our security online, right?
But I didn't know this until recently.
And it's taken my TV watching
game to the next level.
- Tell me more.
- You can use a VPN to unlock movies
and shows that are only
available in other countries.
- Oh my God, I got so excited.
I forgot to even mention that this episode
was sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- The ExpressVPN.
- Gentlemen over the weekend,
I used ExpressVPN to binge
Doctor Who on the UK Netflix.
- No fucking way.
- It was simple, Garnt.
Simple.
- How simple?
- I just fired up ExpressVPN app,
change my location to
the UK refresh Netflix.
And that was it.
- That was so easy.
- So you're telling me
that ExpressVPN hides your
IP address unless you control
where you want the sites
to think you're located?
- That's exactly it.
- Oh my God, I had no idea.
- Not only that,
but you can choose from
almost 100 different countries
more than 99.
- That's 100 more than zero.
That's double fifty.
So just think about all
the Netflix libraries
you can go through.
I'll give you a clue how many libraries.
It's 100.
- Guys i have a question.
Do you love anime?
- No.
- Get outta here.
- Do I love anime?
- Do you love anime, Garnt?
- Connor.
- Did you know that
you can use Express VPN
to access Japanese Netflix
and be spirited away?
- Is that an anime reference?
- It is.
- I would definitely need
that in my position right now.
- But Garnt, it's not just Netflix.
ExpressVPN works with
any streaming service,
Hulu, Hulu, BBC iPlayer.
YouTube, you name it.
It can do it.
Fix my marriage, it can do it.
- I mean, listen, boys,
there are hundreds of VPNs out
there I'm sure we all know.
- Of course.
- BUt the reason I use ExpressVPN
and the reason why you boys use ExpressVPN
is to watch shows.
Because it's just so ridiculously fast.
- How fast Joey?
- There's never any buffering or lag
and you can stream in HD.
No problemmo.
- No jokes aside actually it is good.
This VPN is also compatible
with all of your devices,
phones, media consoles,
smart TVs, and more.
So you can watch what you want on the go
or on the big screen, wherever you are.
- Wherever?
- Whenever Joey.
- Damn.
- And if you go to
expressvpn.com/trashtaste right now,
you can get an extra three free months.
- Three free months?
- Three, that's a lot of frees.
(laughs)
Not three, I don't what I'm saying.
- So support the show,
watch what you want.
And protect yourself at
expressvpn.com/trashtaste,
link's in the description below.
- Check yourself and protect
yourself, back to the show.
- I'll tell you what else
I've been watching recently.
I've been catching up to
Re:Zero season two as well.
- [Connor] Me too.
This is like going back,
how many episodes ago?
Where we're just like we're
gonna get back to Re:Zero.
Here you go fans.
We're getting back to Re:Zero.
- The amount of memes
that came out of that.
- Just one minute later,
don't fucking, the internet
one minute is nothing.
- Yeah.
- Man.
Can I just laugh at something?
- Okay.
- Why is Garfiel a big orange cat?
(laughs)
- I've never thought of that before.
- He literally turns
into a big orange cat.
Have you watched Re:Zero season two?
- No.
- So this one character called Garfiel.
Not, Garfield, Garfiel.
- Garfiel.
- Garfiel,
and he turns into--
- A big orange cat.
- What the fuck?
- Probably hates Mondays.
- Loves lasagna.
- I just I had to like
pause it when this like,
okay, spoilers reserved
when he just starts murdering people.
- Right.
- This cat is just this
fucking chunky Garfield.
- Yeah.
- Murdering people.
I was like, wow.
- Now I wanna watch this.
- Damn what timeline happened
to Garfield when he died bro?
- It's on a Monday probably.
- I feel like you should
Re:Zero season two.
- It's amazing.
- I think it's fucking amazing--
- It's great.
- I need to.
Because I feel like,
have you seen season one?
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
So I feel like we go back
to our conversation earlier,
season one set up the
world really, really well.
But then it I knew it had the
potential to go even further.
And I feel like Re:Zero season two
is definitely hitting that potential.
Yeah, like one thing I really liked
is how in like the first
few episodes of season two,
there were just no deaths.
It was just building up this character.
Like with what happened to
Subaru in the first few episodes.
That was fucking genius.
Because it managed to
build up Subaru's character
in a way that hadn't been like done before
and really just explore who he is
and why he acts the way he does.
- Yeah, because they built up
this almost very childish
mindset that he had,
that we often see in anime
characters, especially Isekai.
And then they kind of just
deconstructed it in season two,
which was amazing because it's like,
I hate this fucking incel
and then they're like,
here's the reason why he didn't say
and why he's going to change.
- I respect that.
- Nice, I like that.
- Yeah, I've only I've only
heard the greatest things.
- 'Cause season one when you saw people
who were like, dude, I relate to Subaru.
I'm like, what's wrong with you?
The fuck (indistinct)
(laughs)
But it's great because it's basically,
they built that all up to be like,
okay, now he's a shady character,
I'm gonna teach him why needs to change.
Why those kind of behavior
and I'm doing all this
for Amelia is toxic.
As it would be.
(indistinct)
- Fucking simping for Amelia.
- Yeah, it's really interesting.
I didn't like it
when I realized what they were first doing
but I started to enjoy it.
So they're using the whole reset thing,
as a way to like slowly build
up this one kind of thing
that they're stuck in right now.
And I thought it was
fucking annoying at first,
so I wanted them to leave the sanctuary.
- Yeah.
- And I really liked
how they're just slowly been
building up through the resets.
- Exactly.
- And you get a piece by piece,
because it feels like almost
like a murder mystery.
Where you're kind of
getting little information.
And it's you built it up really well.
I don't know, I'm just
really into it right now.
And I'm so hyped for it guys.
I have no qualms with that right now.
- Like I'm actually way more
into it than I was season one.
Season one, I very much enjoy.
- Actually, I do have a
thing that I don't like,
Where the fuck is Rem?
I want my bitch back, bro.
I get it.
She's just kind of gone but--
- That's how basic she's bro.
- But we better get like a
full blow job with her back.
- Imma say it.
(laughs)
- Everybody is gonna be like
who is that character
Connor is talking about?
(indistinct)
(laughs)
- Why would you still miss Rem
when this perfect specimen of a beauty
has been introduced to the show.
- I can't get over echidnas.
(laughs)
- Because she has a four penises?
- Yeah, she has four penises.
- Do you wanna explain
why that's the case, Joey?
- Because it was a meme that
I saw in the Sonic fanbase.
It's always a Sonic fanbase
where they're like Knuckles
has four penis heads.
And I was like, what?
And then apparently if
you go into Wikipedia,
you look up like an actual echidnas,
like the animal that's something
that Knuckles is based off.
Yeah, echidnas have four penises.
- Okay, I will admit
she's a top tier Waifu.
She's definitely pulling away.
She broke Subaru down.
- Yeah.
- She like when she got introduced.
She just fucking I was like,
there was some Re:Zero girls liked,
and then there was Beatrice
and then she just came along
and destroyed everything.
- It's literally that meme
with the car drifting.
Like going straight and turning.
It's like Amelia drifting to echidnas.
One short episode,
I will admit, it's tempting.
- Yeah.
- But as a Knight of Rem,
my loyalties cannot be swayed goddammit.
- Your not my queen.
- I'm like I was clowning earlier
about how I'll get serious about it.
Then I literally now do this,
I do not portray my queen.
(chuckles)
If I don't trust men who sway
this simping, you're weak.
Pick a wife and simp goddammit.
- Swaying Waifu is such a weak mind.
- It such a weak mindset.
You would be a terrible.
- What do you even like about Rem.
- What do you mean?
- She's like crouton to the salad, right?
- That's always the best fucking part.
The crunchiest part that you can never...
You don't have to worry
about the amount of dressing on them.
All right, Rem never fails
to just be there, right?
Like Rem is just there, man.
You know what I mean?
- I don't know man.
- Rem came through, she murdered him.
That's hot first of all.
(laughs)
That's hot.
And then she kind ofm she became Owoo,
and I kind of opened to that.
(indistinct)
- Listen I'm not gonna lie I'm
very struggling to remember.
(laughs)
I just remember that
she was loyal to death,
and it was very endearing.
How many times do we get Waifus, right?
That put their heart
on the line like that.
And God's like won't blink,
bring out the note.
- Let me bring out the massive list
of literally probably
90% of Waifus out there.
- But I feel like those Waifus,
they wanted to get the result,
they wanted to be the chosen one.
Whereas Rem confessed knowing full well
she was never gonna be picked
and there's something I
can respect about that.
- I don't know about that one, man.
- Obviously I haven't
watched enough harem anime
'cause that's like every other girl.
(indistinct)
- They say that's what they like.
I know you won't pick me
but it's like in the back of the head.
They don't wanna be picked.
Now Rem totally did it
was just like Chad like,
I know you're not gonna pick me
but I fucking love you
and that's okay, king.
(laughs)
That's what I love about Rem,
that's when that single time
when she confessed I'm like--
- I don't know man.
Didn't she go on an entire spiel of like
how she wants like a
family and stuff and like--
- Do you think I fucking remember that?
- And she's like I want three kids
in a cottage in the hills like.
- Did she, what the fuck!
- I think I remember something like that.
- She pretty set in stone.
- That was definitely like
a flash forward or something
where she had kids with Subaru.
- Practice you pull out game then,
you know what I mean is fine.
(laughs)
I mean, that's fine.
- If it fails you can just reset.
(laughs)
- You're like shit I hope that checkpoint
was over a month ago.
Gonna be real awkward.
- She comes back with like the results.
- You go back to your checkpoint,
it's like two weeks your like,
shit, she's still pregnant.
- You're like fuck go back.
- You're fucking awful people.
- I'm sure there's a fucking dude.
- I don't know.
I can't remember I'll be honest.
I cannot remember--
- To me like just--
- Does like all the knights
know why they fight for the king?
Like shit why are we fighting?
I don't know, I've been
doing it for like 10 years.
I just keep fighting.
- Yeah, but that's such a weak mindset.
- That's a weak mindset bro.
- A weak mindset is swaying
with the wind Garnt like you do.
And you Joey.
- I haven't swayed yet,
I'm still for Beatrice.
- I already know you're gonna
sway I don't even fucking--
- We'll see.
- Honestly, I was never like always--
- Joey is literally that meme of the guy.
(laughs)
- I was in the Beatrice camp because--
- Because you like kids.
(laughs)
- We bringin it there are we Connor?
We bringing it there.
- I don't know what canon age is.
- I'll have you know
your honor that she was--
(laughs)
- This is the problem right?
Let's say your wife who is Beatrice
or she's fucking Shinobu.
- Yeah.
- You go into the movies, right?
- You turn up to the fucking restaurant.
Table for two.
This is my Waifu down here.
We're gonna sit and hold hands.
Come to the table.
- No.
- I can't stand the looks I'm
gonna get at that restaurant.
When I sit down with my fucking
10 year old at the table
and we're playing footsies.
(chuckles)
- Here's a thing, first of all, she's 890,
but second of all--
- Waiter can she drink?
She's 890.
- Yeah of course.
No, but here's the thing is that like,
at least my viewing of
like my enemy Waifus
is that I like them
because they're not real.
Do you know what I'm saying?
- Your honor--
(indistinct)
- We've gone full circle.
- I like them like I don't
want them to be real.
- Do you want a 10 page
thesis on Waifu theory?
- I can give you a 10 page
thesis on Waifu philosophy.
Okay right now, like I don't want
my enemy Waifu to be real
because it's going back to
the whole maid cafe thing,
where it's like you--
- Why do you like kids Joey?
(laughs)
- It's going back to the
whole maid cafe thing
where it's like I like
it because it's not real
and the moment it becomes real,
then you realize, shit, this is not cool.
- Would you be happy with someone
if they fucking murdered
you in a past life?
And you're like, you know
what, we're cool now.
You're loyal to me now.
But you did fucking
murder me that one time.
You did fucking like chop off my legs
and fucking beat me to death,
like three times or something.
- If it was hot.
(laughs)
- That's not like some
people's kink, right?
Like it's like flat lining,
but not coming back.
(laughs)
It's just like, just
actually fucking dying.
- Are we gonna find you
in like (indistinct)
- People are gonna think
I'm into some weird,
but I assure you--
- We're gonna walk up
to your fucking life.
- And we're gonna walk
up to your dead body
and just gonna have the
biggest smile on your face.
- You're gonna be like died by like,
asphyxiation with like 10 stab wounds
and you got like, a big smile.
- I am fortunately I'm pretty vanilla
but I love the idea of the kink.
- That's what I don't
understand about people.
- It's the idea of these
weird things that you could do
that I never wanna do.
- But that's the thing, right?
It's like, that's the thing.
You don't want it to be real.
But so you're okay with it not being real.
That's that's how I see it.
- You're okay with it with loosing.
It's such a weak mindset.
You're okay with it not being real.
You're okay with not growing.
(laughs)
- But that's what I've never
understood about people
who like say that fucking you
know Gasai is their Waifu.
I'm like, what?
Because they openly are like, yeah,
I'd love it if she was
my actual girlfriend.
And I'm like, no you
wouldn't, you would not.
You would not wanna
fucking murderous bitch
as your fucking girlfriend.
(indistinct)
- As an idea Yandere
can be hot, as an idea.
- Yeah.
- But obviously in real life.
- It won't be hot.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely not.
I mean, personally,
I found Gasai like annoying as fuck.
That was no hot.
That was just like, fucking annoying.
The girl I preferred in Mirai Nikki
was the fucks the one with the eyepatch.
- Oh, yeah.
- That chic, I found her way more--
- I like that chic as well.
- I found her way more hot than Yuno.
(indistinct)
- Fuck zero murders I want terrorists.
- Yeah,
- Just give me a terrorist Waifu.
- Mirai Nikki, I was
actually recommending like,
so my Japanese tutor,
she's a Japanese woman.
And she like, takes my anime
recommendations as like gospel.
So I've seen--
- That's your first mistake.
- I've slowly been recommending her
like worse and worse anime
and she started off really into it.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I wanted to see
how much she lied to me.
- Yeah.
- Because I told her to
watch the Future Diary.
I don't know why it came up.
I was like watch it.
I don't particularly like it,
I don't think anyone over
the age of 12 can like it.
- No it's very weird.
- And so she watched it.
She was like yeah, it was good.
I need to think of another one.
I recommended Rent A Girlfriend to her
but I'm sure she'll pick now.
- You got to recommend her something
that's similar to that but just worse.
- What's worse?
- Recommend like Heavy Object.
- I haven't even fucking watched that.
- 'Cause that's made by the
same person as Mira Nikki
but it's a million times worse.
- I haven't watched that yet.
- Oh, it's so bad.
- I'm gonna recommend you--
- You're gonna recommend next?
- Higurashi but in dubs
I'm gonna recommend that.
(laughs)
Like no you have to watch it dubbed.
It's so much better.
(indistinct)
- Yeah, 'cause actual like when they cry.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh my God.
- I recently rewatched Higurashi.
- So I watched Higurashi
dub, cause this is back
when I never watched
dub, because I was like,
no I have to watch dub.
I used to watch on a website
called watch cartoons online.
- Oh my God.
- I remember that website.
Throwback Thursday.
- I always used to be like,
what do you mean there's no dub?
Like cause I refuse to watch
Attack on Titan for a while.
Which is why I just got into
anime like I don't wanna read.
I don't fucking read.
Even though I've been watching...
I've watched every single fucking film
that Jet Li was in, in subtitles.
I don't know why I drew the line--
- Every Jackie Chan movie.
- Yeah, I'd gone through like,
all of Jet Li and Donnie Yen
and Jackie Chan filmography,
'cause I fucking love them.
Yeah, but, fuck what was I saying?
Maylene fucking distracted me.
- You were talking about--
- Yeah, I watched Higurashi
'cause fucking Glass
Reflection recommended it
and I was like cool I'll watch it.
I didn't watch the full video
'cause I didn't want to watch the review.
Later on on the video,
I think he says don't want you to dub
it's fucking terrible, I think.
I was like, well that would
have been nice to know.
Because I watched this thing
and I'm like, what the fuck?
This is awful.
Why is it called When They Cry?
- I've never actually seen a dub.
- It's terrible.
- I think there's one good voice actress
in the entire thing.
And she stands out so much.
- She's carrying it.
- Wait, which character?
- I think it's Shion.
- It's like the fucking
like the one teammate
on league who isn't (indistinct)
Please just group, I can do it.
- Now I need to watch it.
- I love watching horrible.
- I really wish that the license
was in Limbo for the dubs.
We could just watch it live
on Twitch, no problems,
because I would love to do like
we'll watch Higurashi live.
That'd be so fucking--
- That'd be amazing. .
- Oh my God.
But yeah, Higurashi dubs sucks.
- Oh, that's okay,
because the new ones coming out soon,
so yeah remake--
- Which I'm honestly excited for.
- It seems like there's a lot...
I mean, you've done your
seasonal video already.
This seems to be getting back on track
on the just amount of anime that's--
- Just coming full circle,
like just redo all the good shit.
- I mean, they did it with (indistinct)
And they fucking nailed that.
- I mean it kind of like
doing the Hollywood thing now, right?
I hope it doesn't get to the point where--
- Let's just remake everything.
- Yeah, I don't mind the remakes.
I really hope it doesn't get to the point
where one third of the
season is just remakes.
Because I'm gonna be like, fuck.
- Well remember, like the on the trip
that we just came back
from and we're hotel
and they'd remade the first episode
of Detective Conan.
- Yeah, I remember.
- So we were sitting in a hotel.
And we would turn on the
TV and lo and behold,
there was anime on the TV.
- And people were just
like there's anime on TV.
- Without subtitles.
How do I watch this without subtitles?
So it was an episode of Detective Conan.
And it was like, obviously new animation
and we don't religiously
follow Detective Conan.
- Yeah, so we watched it.
I'm like, this must be the new episode--
- Yeah, and I'm like--
- But then the more we watched it,
we were like, wait, hold on.
I know what's gonna happen next.
This is the first episode just remade.
- I just felt like Subaru at that point.
I'm like,
I know what's gonna happen
he's gonna kick that globe
just watch him kick the globe
and then Joey's like, nah
this isn't the first episode,
this is like new animations like,
watch him kick the globe.
He kicked the globe and at that point,
we realized it was just a remake.
- Joey we started doing
this like mad rain man thing
where it started like,
Joey was like, alright,
and then this is gonna happen.
- Yeah, they're like gonna
get in the roller coaster.
- Like exact things, like Joey
this is just fucking weird.
- They're gonna get into the tunnel.
He's gonna get the water go on his cheek
then he come out the heads
gonna be decapitated.
- It was like the Pro Zd video
where he just recycle the
Peter Pan or something.
(laughs)
We were just sitting there fucking--
- Drinking our beer like Joey stop,
this not a fucking talk show.
- I don't know why.
I don't know.
I don't even like
Detective Conan that much.
But for some reason that
first episode just sticks
in my mind so fucking much.
I surprised myself I was like,
well, I actually got that right.
- I am before the comments accusing Joey
of being a high functioning autistic.
(laughs)
With it with Detective Conan episode one,
I am a high functioning autist.
I know exactly what
happens with everything.
- See that.
- I knew exactly what happened
like scene for scene.
- It was worrying.
- And I hadn't seen that first
episode in over 10 years.
So I surprised myself.
- Joey with one beer
fully unlocks his brain.
(laughs)
- To using 100% of my
brain power for that.
- That's exactly how it works.
Is there anything else you
guys have been watching?
- Fuck.
- I know, I have to
watch Higurashi dub now.
- No, I haven't been watching anything,
just been reading Manga.
- I've been reading
Manga as well actually.
- Oh yeah, what you reading?
- There's a new Manga
I discovered recently
that's called...
What's it called again?
Records of Ragnarok.
- Yes.
- That's only like 30 chapters old.
But my God it is fucking great.
- Yeah.
- So to describe what it's about.
So basically, it's it's what the God
of high school anime
should have been right.
It starts off with just a tournament talk
and it's just been tournament
talk this entire time.
So the premise is that
basically imagine like all Gods
in every culture has like this council
and every few 1000 years
they just basically vote
on whether they should
wipe out humanity or not.
And so this time.
- So 2020.
- Yeah, (laughs)
So in the first chapter
they just decide yeah,
humanity is kind of fucked right now
so let's just put them out their misery.
- Is that fucking
(speaking foreign language)
Valkyrie or something?
- Yeah.
- I didn't recognize the English title.
- I don't recognize your
peasant English name.
- Because you had to get
no because I was about
to say that exact same anime
but then you explaining I'm like, no,
this sounds like the one
I'm about to talk about.
- We are talking about the same show here.
- Yeah.
- This sounds pretty fucking cool.
- No, it's fucking awesome.
- Yeah, so then so then like
the Valkyries come along
and be like, let's give humanity a chance.
Maybe they're not total pieces of shit.
Maybe give them a chance
to defend themselves
and so she suggests that they just do
a fucking massive tournament arc--
- As you do with humans.
- So it's like a tournament
arc of some of like,
the most famous humans of all time.
And like the most famous Gods of all time.
- Yeah.
- So fate.
- Pretty much.
- It's basically just fate
but just its fate combined with Baki.
That's that's probably the
best way to explain, yeah.
Because it's It's so fucking over the top
and the first chapter just
starts a tournament arc,
and you just have two
contestants coming out
and just banging the shit out
of each other immediately.
(indistinct) in the UK.
- Yeah, but unlike unlike
God of High School,
you actually get like the
backstories and everyone's story
as they start fighting.
- Yeah.
- Are you throwing shade
Garnt are you throwing shade?
- Yeah I am throwing shade.
- 'Cause I'm currently
reading through that right now
and I'm at the Adam Versus Zeus.
- Adam Versus Zeus.
- Like Adam and Eve.
- Adam and Zeus.
- Did he eat the fucking apple?
- Yeah, he has an apple
in his mouth constantly.
And he's fucking great, so good.
- Adam is so fucking op.
- 'Cause is this fucking like
chad as fuck like massive.
- Is this like a tea list
and enough's incoming?
- Probably, I don't know.
- Because like the appeal of it
is that everyone's fucking op,
and it's like you get the backstory
about how they became op.
So it's like a Baki backstory.
Where everyone has done
something fucking ridiculous
with their lives
and then as you fighting it out
they like kind of one up each other
on like overpowered powers and attacks.
And it's yeah Adam Versus Zeus
felt like a season finale fight
and that's the second fight.
- That's the second fight.
- That's the second fucking fight.
- That's only volume two of I
think currently eight volumes.
Yeah, it's fucking great.
- Yeah.
And I think the one I'm reading right now
is Hercules Versus Jack the Ripper.
- I was gonna ask is
there Jack the Ripper,
there's always a fucking Jack the Ripper.
There's always a fucking
dude who murdered people.
It's not anything impressive.
- People don't even know
if he actually existed.
- Yeah, we don't know.
- Yeah.
- No, now that fight
Hercules Versus Jack the
Ripper is fucking great.
But yeah, I don't know, just I love I know
I say this with every fucking Manga
I recommend but I fucking love the art.
Yeah, it's something so, it's gritty,
but it's also so inoffensive.
Like, it's just like a great showman.
It's just fun.
- I just love how postable it is
and like they have no filler.
No, it's just like,
I know you here for fights.
Here's the fight.
We'll give you the backstory.
So don't fucking worry about it.
Here's a hype matchup
and let's just fucking go.
Chapter one.
And then when the fight finishes,
you get like zero downtime.
- Immediately goes to the next one.
- Yeah.
- Hell yeah.
- Yeah, it's great.
- Sounds amazing.
- The only thing that's
bad about it right now,
is that there are only 30 chapters.
That's pretty much the only downside,
I feel about it right now.
- I reckon though if
that ever gets animated,
and it probably will
considering that it's really big
in Japan right now.
I just really hope that
they don't fucking stretch
that shit out like they did with Baki.
I just wish that they would
just maintain that pace.
- Yeah.
- To be fair Baki is pretty
faster with its fights.
- Yeah, but also they
throw in a load of bullshit
that the market didn't have.
- I guess yeah.
- But then again the Manga
also has like some bullshit
in it where it's like I didn't need
to know about it's like this like,
like fucking Mohammed Ali Jr.
(chuckles)
Is like that his backstory
is like 30 chapters long
and you see him fight
for like two chapters.
- Are we about to on a tangent about Baki?
- I don't think we have
enough time to go--
- We don't have time.
- We need like a full episode for Baki.
- We can do a full episode on Baki.
- Baki is great.
Read it or watch it
before we talk about it .
- We need to get John on the podcast
and just dedicate the episode to Baki.
- Yeah.
- My God.
- No, that's great.
It's fucking awesome.
- As you guys know, I've
been reading Eyeshield 21.
- Yes, Eyeshield 21.
- So fucking amazing.
- I know it's great.
- He's odd is (indistinct)
(indistinct) is a God yeah.
- Like there's some panels
that like just blow you away.
Cause like every like
it's an American football Manga.
And you're kind of like
with the I don't know,
like the rough squad
with a bunch of the crazy characters and--
- Yeah.
- They're the rough around
the edges kind of characters
and team captain is a fucking
psychopath and is amazing.
I thought he was the villain
when he was first introduced.
- He looks like the villain, doesn't he?
- But he's amazing.
Anyway, the whole Manga super endearing.
The story is really unpredictable.
Like you really have no
idea what's gonna happen
and just oh my God the op.
- Yeah.
So if you don't know Murata Yusuke
to use get he did the op for One Punch Man
- Not the original.
- The redrawing, the good one.
- Like there's a panel
where like said crazy
character does a throw.
And he like he like do
an illustration of him.
Like as like a fucking
God throwing a ball.
- Yeah.
- It's like a two page spread
and it's fucking beautiful.
- What I love about that Manga
and well,
no other sports Manga has
managed to match Eyeshield in
is the fucking visual metaphors.
Visual metaphors is why this
Manga just works so well.
- It's insane.
Like, they like oh my God.
There's so many like--
- The first time I saw him
do the fucking devil bat goes
I didn't know.
I fucking nutted.
(chuckles)
I'm like, that is the coolest
fucking thing I've ever seen.
- It's just like the whole,
if you haven't read Eyeshield 21
and you're not into anime.
I fucking thing American football
is the most boring sport on earth.
But the Manga is so good.
- That Manga got me
into American football.
- Yeah.
- It's like that's how I learned
the rules of American football.
And after that Manga I'm like, okay,
I can watch American football now.
- Yeah, it's almost perfect--
(laughs)
- Are gonna talk about that one thing?
- Okay, there's this whole.
This is all I don't know
if they appear again.
I'm about two thirds of the way through.
Maybe they appear in the end again.
So an American team comes over
and there's a black guy
and his superpower is that
he's just black, I guess.
And that's his whole thing
is that he's super powered
because he's black.
And that's why he's a great player.
And it's just kind of like,
when was the Manga made?
- It was Golden Age, wasn't it?
It was mid 2000s.
- Like mid 2000s.
- Yeah.
- I guess mid 2000s and you
could kind of see what--
- I mean it was around the same year
as the questionable Gantz episode.
- Yeah.
And it's like the the
American teams manager
hates black people because he
was replaced by a black player
in the NFL.
- Yeah.
- And then he refers to
like, he's just horrible,
he refers to them as monkeys.
It's so uncomfortable.
- It's just like the most bare
bones exploration of racism.
- Yeah, I guess that's why it's like,
I guess it would be
uncomfortable in real life.
But, it's so like,
what someone would think racism is like,
and know what it is like.
Then it's like, it's just
kind of like, (indistinct)
(indistinct)
- It's just kind of like, yikes,
when you're reading it,
it's just one big yikes.
- It's just so funny to
me that the superpower,
he has no other superpower
apart from just being black.
(laughs)
Like, it's just a mutually agreed fighter
in the Eyeshield world.
Black people are just like, Superman.
- Yeah, there's so many fucking panels
I screenshotted a bunch, where
they're just talking about
how it's like a superpower.
And I was just reading it
with my jaw on the ground.
Like, holy fuck, this is a thing.
- It's poli age Manga panels.
If there's a Twitter account for that.
- It's just like all of Africa
has just a buff in this universe.
(laughs)
Like everyone else, it's just nerfed.
- Oh my God.
There's a line and I'll
set the screenshot.
Without a black men
strong yet flexible body,
it is impossible to
make that kind of play.
(laughs)
This is natural born sprinter,
muscles that only black people have.
(laughs)
I don't think it's the...
I'm not sure if this is
the official translation.
- I'm gonna look at it in Japanese
but I assume it's just as bad.
- It's just a massive you read it
and you're like, okay, it's just one.
Maybe they won't keep doing this.
And they kept doing it.
It's just like, oh fuck.
- Yeah--
- But I guarantee--
- That aside, it is an amazing Manga.
And I know some people probably argue,
you shouldn't forgive that.
It's like it's fucking 2000s Japan
they didn't fucking know any of that shit.
- There were lots of Manga
doing stuff like that.
- They were never expose to it, right?
I get it they wanna touch on it
but it's like I just
fucking speed on that point.
- And there's like worse way to be viewed
than just being good at being a fucking--
- At least they didn't like,
straight up, drop the N bomb.
(laughs)
- At least they were
subtle about it in a sense.
If they dropped the N bomb,
they were like, alright, yeah,
maybe it's time we talk
about this but you know.
- It's just a yikes to
read and your like okay.
- It's just like one little phone.
That's just hurts a little bit.
- Because you wanna recommend it
and you want to tell how amazing it is.
And then you just gotta be like,
there's just this one thing.
- There's one thing you should be careful.
(laughs)
- It is an amazing Manga just be prepared
when you get to that part.
- This episode Of Trash Taste.
I wanna say a lovely thank you
to the beautiful patrons on screen.
- Look at all of them.
- Look at this beautiful motherfuckers.
- I love them all,
- Look at the beautiful name.
- This guy is a motherfucker,
I love this guy.
- I love this guy.
- Really you think that guy.
- I simp this guy though.
- If you want us to simp
over you then you can do so
by going over to our patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste down on the screen
and simping us.
- Thank you so much
because without you we
couldn't do all the cool shit
that is coming on very shortly.
- Yeah, there's a lot of cool shit
that we're planning on right now.
- And the patreons are there
to support us for that.
So make sure to go over to there.
- Also check out our Twitter
and subreddit as well
as post your horrible
memes and shit posts.
We love going through them every day.
- Fat cock.
- Yeah, fat cock.
- If you're welcome to,
you can join me in the VTubers hall.
- Join us.
- Join us in the VTubers hall.
- I'm gonna come back next
week like hovering in my chair.
Gentlemen I have discovered.
- Gentlemen I have reached enlightened.
I've seen the lights.
- Yes.
- Anime girls on stream.
Thank you gentlemen.
That'll be all.
(laughs)
- Goodbye.
- See yah.
- See you next time.
(upbeat music)